ALAN ARCHULETA AT KANSAS STATE
PEPPER LARGEST BRADFORD KABY
YELLOW CORTEZ THREE DALLY DODD
RUSSELL A GIVEN LASER GUNS
ALLAH'S ROVE HERZ BERG WAY SO
HER TADO JONES CAN LONGER
LAYERED LEYVA THE MON MCGUIRE
MELINDA'S MAN NEWMAN NIELSEN
TELEVOTING PAN FOURTEEN TINO
RALPH RUBIO SKINNER STERN.
AMBERG WHAT HOW SKI WINNER WILL.
MEMBERS OF THE QUORUM IS
PRESENT WITH THE MEMBERS AND
OUR GUESTS BEYOND THE RAIL AND
IN THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE WHO
WE WILL BE LED IN PRAYER THIS
MORNING BY SENATOR EDMUND AFTER
WHICH PLEASE REMAIN STANDING WE
WILL BE LED IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. BY
SENATOR TO LET THEM. LET US
PRAY FROM PSALM NINETY.
INTERNAL AND IMMORTAL ONE YOU
HAVE BEEN OUR REFUGE AND ALL
GENERATIONS. BEFORE THE
MOUNTAINS WERE BROUGHT FORTH
BEFORE YOU HAD FORMED THE EARTH
AND THE COSMOS. FROM
EVERLASTING TO EVERLASTING YOU
ARE THE ALPHA AND THE OMEGA.
WHEN OUR DAYS ON EARTH- ENDED
YOU WELCOME US HOME TO YOUR
HEART TO THE CITY OF LOVE WHAT
TIME IS A TURTLE. AND DAYS ARE
NOT NUMBERED. YOU GATHER THOSE
YOU LOVE AS FRIENDS RETURNING
FROM A LONG JOURNEY. GIVING
REST TO THEIR SOULS. UNITE THEM
WITH THE BOMB OF UNDERSTANDING
HEALING WOUNDS OF THE PAST. TO
JUST SO BELOVED TO HONOR EACH
DAY. THAT WE MAY HAVE A HEART
AND WISDOM. HAVE MERCY ON YOUR
PEOPLE'S PAIN. INCREASE YOUR
LOVE WITHIN US. AND HEAR OUR
PRAYER. EVEN THIS MORNING
CENTERS. WHERE WE HONOR THE MEN
AND WOMEN WHO ARE SERVING IN
AFGHANISTAN. AND ALL THOSE ARE
SERVING ACROSS THE WORLD.
PLEASE PUT YOUR HAND OVER YOUR
HEART FOLLOW ME. I PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA WE.
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. MEMBERS ARE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO PRIVILEGES
OF THE FLOOR. SENATOR PENN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT- GOOD MORNING MEMBERS
I RISE TODAY TO RECOGNIZE KEEPS
HEALTHCARE HE BEGAN HIS
EMPLOYMENT WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE IN FEBRUARY
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR AS A
TELEVISION SPECIALISTS LATER
PROMOTING TO PRODUCTION MANAGER
IN THE NINETEEN NINETY. SIX HE
DISPLAYED THE UTMOST
PROFESSIONALISM AND WORKED
TIRELESS HOURS TELEVISING
HISTORIC ELECT ELECTRICAL
RESTRUCTURING HEARINGS CHAIRED
BY SENATOR STEVE PEACE WITH
NUMEROUS OVERSIGHT HEARINGS.
AND GENERATE TWO THOUSAND KEITH
WAS INTEGRAL TO THE
COORDINATING THE TELEVISING
RECORDING OF THE SENATE SESSION
FROM HISTORIC BENICIA CAPITOL
STATE PARK WHICH IS HELD IN
HONOR OF THE HUNDRED FIFTIETH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE LEGISLATORS FIRST MEETING
WITH UNPARALLELED PASSION FOR
HIS CRAFT HE SUCCESSFULLY
COORDINATED AN UPGRADE OF THE
SENATE'S TELEVISION VIDEO
SYSTEM IN THE STATE CAPITOL IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN. MOVING THE
SENATE INTO THE DIGITAL AGE AS
MUCH AS WE CAN BE MOVED TO THE
DIGITAL AGE WITH HIGH
DEFINITION PICTURES AND ONLINE
VIDEO STREAMING. OVER THE
COURSE OF HIS TENURE NEVER MISS
THE BUDGET VOTE FOR AN END OF
SESSION AND I'VE CERTAINLY I'VE
HAD PERSONALLY HAD THE HONOR OF
WORKING WITH KEITH. ON SENATE
TV YOU CAN ATTEST TO HIS
TREMENDOUS DEDICATION. I WOULD
TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO THANK
THE FIRST TWENTY SEVEN YEARS OF
SERVICE THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE AND SHARE OUR
APPRECIATION FOR THE SERVICES
PROVIDED TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WELCOME BACK TO
LATE AMONG HIS RETIREMENT AS
WE'RE COMING TO OUR END OF
SESSION AND AGAIN
CONGRATULATIONS KEEP- THANK YOU
SO VERY MUCH FOR YOUR SERVICE
AND LET'S- SURE APPRECIATION
FOR THE SERVICES PROVIDED THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. GOING TO
YOUR TAX. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
HE FELT CAMP FOR YOUR SERVICE
TO THE SENATE- IN APPRECIATE
ALL THE WORK THAT YOU'VE DONE
AND- WISH YOU WERE HERE ON THE
FLOOR WITH THIS BUT WE'RE
KEEPING EVERYBODY SAFE SO THANK
YOU FOR IT SO MUCH FOR JOINING
US HERE TODAY. MOVING ON TO
SENATOR BATES. THANK YOU I'M A
PRESIDENT I RISE THIS MORNING
TO PAY TRIBUTE TO ONE OF THE
SENATE'S UNSUNG HEROES. HERE
AND THE- LEANING. BEFORE SHE
ENTERS RETIREMENT. KAREN HAS
WORKED. BEHIND THE SCENES WHO
ALONG WITH THEIR HARD WORKING
COLLEAGUES HANDLE MANY OF THE
IMPORTANT TASKS NECESSARY FOR
US. THE SENATORS TO DO OUR
JOBS. OVER THE PAST THIRTEEN
YEARS SHARON HAS SERVED AS OUR
DEPUTY SECRETARY. OF OPERATIONS
FOR THE SENATE RULES COMMITTEE.
SHE DOES HANDLE LAURA REQUEST
AND BE HAVE SOME PAYMENTS. AND
THE SEND US MAIL PROGRAM. CHAIR
AND ALSO HAD A ROLE IN CREATING
AND MANAGING. OPERATIONS FOR
THE RULES COMMITTEES TRAINING
OFF OF. SOCIAL MEDIA. VANS
CEREMONIAL FUNCTIONS. MEMORIALS
AND MORE SHARE AND LEARN HOW TO
HANDLE THE COME AND STRESS OF
HER JOB HAVING GROWN UP ON ONE
OF MONTEREY COUNTY'S OLDEST
FAMILY CATTLE RANCHES. THERE
SHE GREW UP CATTLE BEING RAISED
OUTSIDE HER FRONT DOOR AND WAS
A MEMBER OF THE LOCALFOUR H.
CLUB. BOTH OF WHICH TAUGHT HER
A STRONG WORK ETHIC AND
COMMITMENT TO THE RANCHING LIFE
THAT IS HER FAMILY'S HISTORY.
LIKE MANY OF OUR STAFF MEMBERS
DO SHARON FIRST CAME TO THE
CAPITAL AS AN INTERN. AND AFTER
A SHORT NINE YEAR BREAK FOUND
HER WAY BACK AS CHIEF OF STAFF
FOR THEN ASSEMBLYMAN DICK
ACKERMAN IN NINETEEN NINETY
SIX. SHE CONTINUED TO WORK WITH
ASSEMBLYMAN ACKERMAN TO HIS
TIME AS SENATOR. AND EVENTUALLY
BECAME THE DEPUTY CHIEF OF
STAFF FOR THE SENATE REPUBLICAN
CAUCUS WHEN SENATOR ACKERMAN
BECAME OUR REPUBLICAN LEADERS.
WE CONNECTED WITH SENATOR AFTER
MANNING HERE'S SOME OF WHAT HE
HAD TO SAY CANACCORD I WORKED
FOR SHARING FOR ALMOST ALL OF
MY THIRTEEN YEARS IN THE
LEGISLATURE. SHE WAS MY CHIEF
OF STAFF IN BOTH THE ASSEMBLY
AND SENATE. HER CHARACTER
ATTITUDE SENSE OF HUMOR AND
JUDGMENT MADE OUR OFFICE THE
FUN AND EFFECTIVE PLACE TO
WORK. WE SERVED UNDER THREE
GOVERNORS MULTIPLE SPEAKERS AND
A COUPLE OF PROTONS HER
CONNECTIONS AND RESPECT IN THE
BUILDING. WERE INVALUABLE SHE
HAD GREAT RELATIONSHIPS WITH
BOTH DEMOCRAT. AND REPUBLICAN
STAFFERS IN THE ASSEMBLY. THE
SENATE AND THE ADMINISTRATION
SHARON WAS ABLE TO SECURE
FUNDING TO REFURBISH A SMALL
RESERVOIR IN FULLERTON CALLED
LAGUNA LAKE. IN ADDITION
SOMEHOW SHE WAS ABLE TO GET
FISH SUPPLIED FOR LOCAL KID
FISHERMEN. I NEVER DID FIND OUT
HOW SHE DID THAT. THIS LAKE WAS
VERY IMPORTANT TO ME AS IT
SERVES AS THE HOME BASE FOR THE
FULLER TEN YACHT CLUB
CONTRIBUTIONS TO OUR OFFICE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WERE
ENORMOUS GOOD LUCK IN YOUR NEW
VENTURE. IS MENTAL FITNESS
COACH AND DICK SAID WHERE DO I
SIGN UP END QUOTE. AGAIN THOSE
ARE THE WORDS OF SENATOR
ACKERMAN IT WOULD NOT BE LIKE
SHARON TO REST IN RETIREMENT.
AND WE KNOW THAT SHE HAS
ALREADY STARTED A NEW ENDEAVOR
TO USE HER SKILLS AS A MENTOR
TO TRAIN INDIVIDUALS TO RESPOND
TO LIFE'S CHALLENGES. AND
OVERCOME NEGATIVE MINDSETS
PLEASE JOIN ME IN
CONGRATULATING AND THANKING
SHERRIN. HER HOLD HER OVER
TWENTY FIVE YEARS OF SERVICE
AND CONTRIBUTION TO THE SENATE.
AND TO THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. WE WISH HER ALL THE
BEST IN HER NEW ADVENTURES. THE
WORMS IN IT. THANK YOU TO SURE
AND BELIEVE ME THANK YOU FOR
YOUR YEARS OF SERVICE AND MAY
YOU ENJOY RETIREMENT AND
WHATEVER THE NEXT JOURNEY IS-
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR- YOUR
RETIREMENT. MOVING ON TO
SENATORS IN THE MORNING
FOLLOWED BY SENATOR BRADFORD.
THANK YOU. I RISE TO
CONGRATULATE AND THINK I ONLY
KNEW HALL FOR HER TWO PLUS
DECADES OF SERVICE TO THE STATE
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
LEGISLATURE AFTER A CAREER AS A
GEOLOGIST EILEEN SERVED AS AN
EXECUTIVE FELLOW IN NINETEEN
NINETY FOUR AND BEGAN STATE
SERVICE IN NINETEEN NINETY SIX.
PRIOR TO JOINING THE STATE THE
SENATE BANKING COMMITTEE EILEEN
SERVED AS PRINCIPAL CONSULTANT
FOR THE ASSEMBLY REV AND TAX
COMMITTEE OF HER MANY
LEGISLATIVE ACCOMPLISHMENTS AT
LEAST AS I LEAN IS MOST PROUD
OF HELPING DRAFT AND STAFF
LEGISLATION PERTAINING TO. THE
PROHIBITION OF ADVANCE FEES IN
CONNECTION WITH MORTGAGE LOAN
MODIFICATION ASSISTANCE.
REGULATORY OVERSIGHT OF
MORTGAGE LOAN ORIGINATORS AND
PROVIDING MULTIPLE PATHWAYS FOR
LOW AND MODERATE INCOME
CALIFORNIANS TO ESTABLISH
CREDIT SCORES AND IMPROVE THEIR
FINANCIAL WELL BEING THE
CAPITAL COMMUNITY WILL GREATLY
MISS WORKING WITH EILEEN SHE
DEVELOPED BREAST OF
INSTITUTIONAL KNOWLEDGE THAT
WILL NOT BE THAT WE WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO REPLACE. WELL OUR TIME
TOGETHER WAS BRIEF I CANNOT
THINK I MEAN ENOUGH FOR HER
GUIDANCE HER MANY YEARS OF
SERVICE AND THE DEDICATION TO
THE BANKING COMMITTEE. AND TO
THE WORK OF THE SENATE ENJOY
YOUR RETIREMENT EILEEN.
REGULATIONS TO I MEAN NEW HALL
WE'RE GOING TO MISS YOU IN
BANKING- AND MAYBE I'LL GO BACK
TO. WHAT YOU STARTED OFF YOUR
CAREER DOING GEOLOGY. WHAT IS
IT SENATOR BRADFORD MY
APOLOGIES THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I TOO YOU JUST WANT
TO RISE AND SAY THANK YOU TO
MISS NEW ALL FOR ALL OF HER
EXPERTISE IN TWO YEARS THAT I
SERVED AS- BANKING CHEER I
CAN'T. THANK HER ENOUGH THAT
ALWAYS BEING PREPARED AND
ALWAYS HAVING THE RIGHT ANSWERS
YOU WANT WHEN I NEEDED HIM WHEN
I WAS UNSURE WHICH WAY TO GO
SHE WAS ALWAYS THERE. AND JUST
ALWAYS PREPARED I MEAN
THOROUGHLY NINE MOST
CONSULTANTS IN THIS BUILDING OR
ARE GOOD AT THEIR JOB BUT
EILEEN IS EXCEPTIONAL ALL THE
TIME AND- KNEW ALL THE INS AND
OUTS OF BANKING AND FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS SO. DURING SOME
TOUGH TIMES IT'S PAYDAY LENDING
AND YOU KNOW- ALL THOSE ISSUES
THAT HAVE COME ONLINE LENDING
THAT WERE NEW TO MANY OF US
HERE HE WAS ON TOP OF IT AND
WAS READY. SO I KNOW EILEEN IS
NOT GONNA RETIRE FROM HER REAL
PASSION AND THAT'S RUNNING
USUALLY AFTER A LONG WEEKEND I
WOULD SAY WHAT DID YOU DO IT
SHE'S ALL I WENT ON A THIRTEEN
MILE. JOG YOU CAN ARRIVE I
THINK MANY TIMES HE LEFT THE
BUILDING AT THE LONG HOURS
SIMPLY TO GO RUN THAT'S YOUR
PASSION SO I HOPE YOU CONTINUE
WRITING INTERESTING ENJOY WHAT
YOU DO AT THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
YOUR TREMENDOUS SERVICE AND-
YOUR HELP AND STEWARDSHIP. IN
MAKING ME A BETTER CHAIR. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU TO A
NEW HOME MOVING ON TO A SENATOR
UMBERG. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES WE ARE
REALLY HONORED TO HAVE MR
CHESTERTON IS THE VERY CHECK
THERE AND CHECK THEM AND THAT'S
WHY POLICE SAY HERE WITH US IN
THE CHAMBER DARREN IS A PRODUCT
OF ORANGE COUNTY AND A LONG
STANDING AND LONG SUFFERING
ANGELS FAN. HE'S BEEN HERE FOR
THIRTY FOUR YEARS- WHERE HE'S
BEEN CONSULTANT AND PRINCIPAL
CONSULTANT ON ELECTIONS
COMMITTEE SINCE NINETEEN NINETY
THREE. NOW I- SCOTT MUST MOTO
DURING YOU'LL APPRECIATE THIS.
HE PROVIDED ME HERE'S A COPY OF
WHAT THE ELECTIONS CODE LOOK
LIKE. HUNDRED FORTY YEARS THIS
IS WHAT THE ELECTIONS CODE LOOK
LIKE. IN YOUR THIRTY FOUR YEARS
HERE IT IS NOW DOUBLED IN SIZE.
SO CONGRATULATIONS. FOR. THIS
COMPENDIUM AARON IS AN EXPERT
IN ALL THINGS ELECTION HE HAS
WORKED TO EXPAND THE FRANCHISE
FOR MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS-
HE AND LISA ARE GOING TO ENJOY
IT. WELL DESERVED RETIREMENT
AND SPEND MORE TIME WITH THEIR
THREE CHILDREN J. GRANT AND
NEIL AND THERE TO-
GRANDCHILDREN MAX AND LUCAS
LISA AND AARON THANK YOU SO
MUCH ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE FOR
YOUR SERVICE TO CALIFORNIA AND
ALL OF US. THANK YOU. SENATOR
NIELSEN. THEY'RE ON THE AND
MEMBERS LET ME ADD MY VOICE TO
THIS TRIBUTE TO A GREAT
EMPLOYEE OF THE STATE
LEGISLATURE. GET OUT EVEN
AROUND ALMOST AS LONG AS I
HAVE. AND THE CONTRIBUTIONS
THAT THESE FOLKS KIND OF IN THE
BACKGROUND DUE TO THE
INSTITUTION NOT JUST TO THE
POLICY THAT THEY'RE RESPONSIBLE
FOR THIS CASE ELECTIONS. BUT TO
THE INSTITUTION THE RULES OF
THE INSTITUTION THE COMPORT
YELL AT THE THEY ARE KEEPING
BONDS TO CONTINUE THAT SO I
WANT TO THANK YOU AS YOU MOVE
ON TO NEW CHALLENGES AND
OPPORTUNITIES IN YOUR FUTURE
THANK YOU FOR CHILDREN FOR US
AND FOR THE SENATE. SENATOR ON.
WHEN I ALSO JOINED IN- THIS
PRAISE FOR DERREN CHESS AND I
WHEN I WAS FIRST ELECTED TO
THIS BODY IN TWENTY FOURTEEN A
PRO TEM DE LEON ASKED ME TO
SERVE AS CHAIR OF OUR ELECTIONS
ACROSS USUAL MEMBERS COMMITTEE
AND WAS A REALLY A FANTASTIC
EXPERIENCE A FASCINATING
COMMITTEE WITH VERY INTERESTING
ISSUES. FOLKS MIGHT REMEMBER
THAT TWENTY FOURTEEN WAS IT WAS
A HISTORICALLY LOW TURNOUT
ELECTION R. FOR OUR STATE- THE
NUMBERS WERE JUST AWFUL- AND IT
REALLY THERE WERE A LOT OF
ARTICLES ABOUT ABOUT THE LACK
F PARTICIPATION THE LACK OF
INTEREST IN OUR DEMOCRACY. AND
THE PRO TEM TASKS DARREN AND ME
WITH GETTING TO THE ROOT OF
THIS ISSUE AND TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT WAYS TO ADDRESS THIS THIS
CHALLENGE AND- WE ENDED UP
SPENDING A LOT OF TIME STUDYING
OTHER STATE MODELS AND WE
TRAVELED TO COLORADO. TO LEARN
ABOUT THE MODEL THAT THEY HAD
THEIR- WE REALLY POURED OVER
THE DATA AND ENDED UP WORKING
VERY CLOSELY TOGETHER TO
DEVELOP BEST BEFORE FIFTY WHICH
IS THE BILL THAT CREATED THE
NEW MODEL THAT WE HAVE WITH
THIS COMBINATION OF A VOTE BY
MAIL PLUS VOTE CENTERS THAT HAS
LED TO DRAMATIC INCREASES IN
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION. AND DONE
SO IN A WAY THAT PROTECTS
ELECTORAL INTEGRITY AND
PROVIDES PEOPLE WITH A LOT MORE
OPPORTUNITIES TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE PROCESS THE IDEA THAT WE
HAD WAS THAT IT'S CRAZY TO TELL
PEOPLE IN THIS MODERN ERA- WITH
ALL OF THE CONFUSION AND
MADNESS OF MODERN LIFE THAT
THEY HAVE TO ONLY WE CAN ONLY
VOTE IN ONE PLACE AT ONE TIME
IN ONE LOCATION. ON ONE DAY ON
A TUESDAY OF ALL THINGS- AND
THAT'S THE ONLY WAY THEY CAN
PARTICIPATE IN SELECTING THE
LEADERSHIP OF THEIR STATE OR
THEIR NATION- WE SAID THIS IS
CRAZY WE LET LET'S LET'S FIGURE
OUT A DIFFERENT MODEL AND OUT
AS THEY SAY BY THE MODEL WE NOW
HAVE IS LARGELY BASED ON WHAT
THEY DO IN COLORADO. AND WE'VE
SEEN RECORD. I TURN OUT NOW-
THAT THAT HAS GOT IN THIS BOX
TRACK AND I JUST SAY THAT
DURING WAS ABSOLUTELY INTEGRAL
TO THIS PROCESS. BY DOING ALL
THE WORK LEARNING ABOUT ALL THE
MODELS COMING UP WITH THE DATA
WORKING WITH OUR COLLEAGUES
FROM ACROSS THE AISLE- WORKING
THROUGH ISSUES WITH THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. REALLY
PULLING IN- DATA AND STORIES
FROM OTHER STATES. WORKING WITH
OUR REGISTRAR RECORDER'S WHO
HAVE ALL SORTS OF- THEY HAD ALL
SORTS OF NERVOUSNESS ASSOCIATED
WITH. THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
BILL THE RELAY LIKE CERTAIN
PARTS OF IT BUT THEY WERE ALSO
NERVOUS ABOUT OTHERS. IT WAS A
HERCULEAN EFFORT. AND HE WAS AT
THE HEART OF THIS EFFORT AND I
THINK HE REALLY HAS HAS
CHANGED. HI V. D. M. IN SO MANY
WAYS LARGE AND SMALL BUT THIS
IS ONE EXAMPLE OF HOW HE HAS
HELPED. TO CHANGE V. A. N. AND
IMPROVE THE ROBUSTNESS. OF
DEMOCRACY HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND THIS IS ONE
JUST ONE EXAMPLE ON ON ON
TRANSPARENCY- MATTERS WHERE WE
WORK TOGETHER ON BILLS TO
IMPROVE TRANSPARENCY SO MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC. COULD HAVE A
BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF THE WAY
THAT THIS PLACE WORKS. AND THE
INFLUENCE OF MONEY IN THE
ENGAGEMENT OF CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTIONS- WE WORK TOGETHER
ON A NUMBER OF IMPROVING SOME
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS THAT
WERE MAKING THEIR WAY THROUGH
SO. IT WAS A GREAT PARTNERSHIP
A GREAT FRIENDSHIP- DERREN IS I
CAN'T AGREE ENOUGH WITH THAT
WITH OUR COLLEAGUE CENTER
KNEELS IN THERE AND IT IS IT IS
AN EXEMPLARY. PUBLIC SERVANT.
HE HAS MADE CALIFORNIA BETTER.
AND WE WISH HIM ALL THE VERY
BEST. AS HE MOVES ON IN HIS
CAREER BUT I JUST HAVE TO SAY
ON BEHALF OF A OF AT LEAST ONE
VERY GRATEFUL SENATOR THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THANK. YOU
DURING TESTING FOR ALL YOU'VE
DONE FOR THIS INSTITUTION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AARON JANSSEN
FOR ALL OF YOUR SERVICE AND-
THANK YOU TO ALL OF THE- THOSE
AT A WRECK WERE RECOGNIZED HERE
TODAY WE COULDN'T DO OUR JOB
WITHOUT YOU IN YOUR- YOUR
EXPERTISE AND YOUR-
PARTICIPATION AS IT. IS I
GREATLY APPRECIATED. THANK YOU.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ MESSAGES FROM
THE ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED
READ. REPORTS OF COMMITTEE WILL
BE DEEMED DREAD AD AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED. MEMBERS ARE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS
AND- NOTICES WITHOUT WITH
WITHOUT OBJECTION. MEASURES
REPORTED FROM THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WITH
THE RECOMMENDATION OF DO PASS
WILL BE GIVEN THEIR SECOND
READING UPON BEING REPORTED IN
ORDER TO THIRD READING. WITHOUT
OBJECTION MEASURES REPORTED
WITH THE RECOMMENDATION TO PASS
AS AMENDED WILL BE GIVEN THEIR
SECOND READING AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED AND RETURNED TO SECOND
READING READING UPON BEING
REPORTED MEMBERS NOW'S THE TIME.
FOUR FIVE MOVING. SENT SENATOR
MENENDEZ I WILL RECOGNIZE YOU
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS PURSUANT TO SET RULE
TWENTY EIGHT MAKING A
RESOLUTION WITHDRAWAL ESSERE
FIVE FROM THE SENATE
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE AND BROUGHT TO THE
SENATE FLOOR SO WE CAN HAVE A
FULL AND VIGOROUS DEBATE HAS
BEEN FIVE HUNDRED THIRTY ONE
DAYS SINCE THE GOVERNOR
DECLARED A STATE OF EMERGENCY.
EVERYONE WANTS THE VACCINE CAN
GET ONE AND SIXTY FIVE POINT 6%
OF CALIFORNIANS ARE NOW FULLY
VACCINATED THE MANDATES
CONNECTED TO THIS PANDEMIC ARE
CAUSING CHAOS IT WAS REPORTED
THAT CAL OSHA WILL BE UPDATING
YOUR WORKPLACE STANDARDS
REGARDING FACE COVERINGS UNTIL
DECEMBER CAUSING CONFUSION ON
WHO HAS TO WEAR THEM AND WHEN.
MANDATES TO GET VACCINATED HAD
TEMPERS FLARING AND COULD LEAD
TO A VERY REAL POSSIBILITY THAT
OUR HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE
SHORTAGE WILL ONLY GET WORSE AT
A TIME. WHEN WE NEED PROVIDERS
MOST FOR THESE CRISES ARE
HAPPENING WITH A FOCUS ON THE
SECOND STIMULUS PAYMENT FOR
CERTAIN CALIFORNIA'S NEXT MONTH
HOWEVER. WE WOULD NEED TO BE
SUPPORTING PEOPLE IF WE CAN GET
THEM BACK TO WORK IN THE FIRST
STEP IN THE PROCESS. IS TO IN
THE STATE OF EMERGENCY I ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS SENATOR
MCGUIRE. THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
THAT A PRESIDENT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO VOTE
SENATOR MCGUIRE ASTRONOVA
SENATOR MELINDA'S ASPIRIN I
VOTE. AND SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ALAN NO ARCHULETA NO
ATKINS FACE I BACKER. NO PORGES
HI BRADFORD NO BY ADAM NO
CORTESE NO DALLY I DON. TORONTO
NO EGGMAN. NO GLAZER NO GUNS
ALLAH'S NO GROWTH FIVE FIRSTS
BERG WITH SO HER TADO NO JONES
I CAN LONGER NO FLARED NO LLEVA
NO THE MON NO MCGUIRE NO
MELINDA'S I MEN NO NEWMAN
NIELSEN HI A SHOW OF BOTH HI
PAM NO FORTUNE TINO NO ROTH NO
RUBIO NO SKINNER NO STERN NO
AMBERG OKAY NO LIKE HOW SKI
WINNER NO WELL. HI PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AT KIN DODD
HERTZBERG WEST SO NO NEWMAN
WHITE HOUSE STAY. ICS HI YEAH I
NINE KNOWS TWENTY SIX THE
MOTION FAILS MEMBERS WERE STILL
ON MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES IS THERE ANY ARE THERE
ANY MEMBERS THAT WISH TO PULL
BILLS FROM CONSENT- TO MOVE IN
AFTER FILES OR RETURN THE BILL
TO THE ASSEMBLY FOR FURTHER
ACTION. SENATOR HER DAUGHTER
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I'D
LIKE TO REMOVE FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWO TWO EIGHT AP TOP EIGHTY
THREE FROM CONSENT FOR
AMENDMENTS IN ORDER IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE. SEEING NONE MANY
MOVE ON TO CONSIDERATION OF THE
DAILY FILE MOVING ON TO SECOND
READING FILE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT
FIFTY SEVEN AND ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE THIRTY NINE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MOVING ON THE
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS SENATOR
BATES. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT WILL BEGIN WITH FILE
ITEM NUMBER FOUR WHICH IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF CHRISTOPHER
CHASE FOR APPOINTMENT TO THE
BOARD OF FORESTRY AND FIRE
PROTECTION. KELLY RUNOFFS
SHOULDN'T GO ANY VET WILLIS FOR
APPOINTMENT TO THE BOARD OF
BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES AND YOUR
HONDA ARE TOO WEAK FOR
REPORTING A REAPPOINTMENT TO
THE COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING THESE
APPOINTMENTS FROM TWENTIES WERE
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON JULY FOURTEENTH. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
VOTE IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS. APPOINTMENT ON
THESE APPOINTMENTS SEEING NONE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA HI AT KINS BATES I
BECKER HI FORGES HI BRADFORD I
KERR BY ADAM HI CORTESE FIVE
DALLY I DON THERE ARE SO I
EGGMAN I GLAZER I CONSOLIDATE
FIVE GROWTH BY HERTZ BERG WHY
SO I HER TADO HI JONES I CAN
LONGER I LAYERED HI LLEVA I THE
MON I REQUIRE I MELINDA'S FIVE
MIN HI NEWMAN NIELSEN I A SHOW
OF BOTH I PAN BY FORCING TINA
I. ROSS HI RUBIO I SKINNER HI
STERN I AM BERG I LIKE ASKING
WINNER I WILL HI HI PLEASE CALL
THE UPSET MEMBERS ATKINS DODD
HERTZBERG. NEWMAN WHITE HOUSE
GATE. FIVE THIRTY FIVE NO ZERO
THE APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED
LIVING ON ITEM NUMBER FIVE
SENATOR BATES THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT VIOLENT ITEM NUMBER
FIVE IS A CONFIRMATION OF LANA
BAILEY CRIMMINS AS CHIEF OF THE
OFFICE OF TECHNOLOGY SERVICES
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY
SHE STARTED HER CAREER IN STATE
SERVICE OVER THIRTY YEARS AGO
AND PRIOR TO THIS ROLE SHE WAS
SERVING AS CHIEF INFORMATION
SECURITY OFFICER FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
RETIREMENT SYSTEM. SHE WAS
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON JULY FOURTEENTH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR ADULT
FOR ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS- COMP CONFIRMATION SAYING
NINE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
HI ARCHULETA I AT KINS BASED I
BECKER FIVE FORGES HI BRADFORD
I COME BY ADAM ARE YOU
PROTESTING FIVE DALLY I DON
TORONTO HI ADNAN I BLAZER HI
CONSOLIDATES MY GROWTH ARE YOU
HURTS BERG WESTERN HI HER TADO
HI JONES I CAN LONGER I LAYERED
ON FIVE FLAVA HI THE MON I
REQUIRE I MELINDA'S FIVE MIN I
NEWMAN NIELSEN I COULD SHOW
BOTH I PAN I PERSON TINA HI
RALPH I REVIEW FIVE SKINNER I
STERN HI I'M BURKE I LIKE HOW
STEVE WEINER I WOKE HI PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS NO.
FIVE THIRTY FIVE NO ZERO
DEPARTMENT IS CONFIRMED I
DIDN'T- OF HIGHLIGHTED NUMBER
SIX SENATOR BATES THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIX IS THE CONFIRMATION
OF DOCTOR LOOPY FINALLY MY
LIMITACTIVITIES DIRECTOR OF
THE CHILD CARE AND DEVELOPMENT
DIVISION AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES PRIOR TO THIS
IS TO DISAPPOINTMENT SHE WAS
SERVING THE FRESNO COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS AS
SENIOR DIRECTOR FOR THE EARLY
CARE AND EDUCATION SHE WAS
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON JULY FOURTEENTH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS APPOINTMENT.
SEEING NONE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ALAN HI ARCHULETA I AT
KINS. EIGHT FIVE BACKER I
FORGES I BRADFORD I KERR BY
ADAM I OR TEN THIRTY FIVE DALLY
FIVE DODD THERE ARE SO I ADMIN
FIVE GLAZER HI CONSOLIDATES
FIVE GROWTH HI HURTS BERG
QUESTION HI HER TADO BY JONES I
CAN LONGER I LAYERED I LIVE ON
I LIVE ALONE I REQUIRE I
MELINDA'S I MEN. HI NEWMAN
NIELSEN I. OTERO ABODE HI PAM
FIVE PERSON TINA HI RALPH I
REVERE I SKINNER I STERN I AM
BERG I LIKE KATHLEEN WEINER HI
WELL I. FIVE THIRTY FIVE NO
ZERO THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONCURRED. MEMBERS ARE GONNA
MOVE ON TO UNFINISHED BUSINESS
WE'LL START WITH ITEM NUMBER
NINETEEN SENATOR SKINNER. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL TWENTY SIX BY SENATOR
SKINNER AN ACT RELATING TO
COLLEGIATE ATHLETICS AND
DECLARING THE URGENCY THERE OF
SICK BACK TO ME IMMEDIATELY
CENTERS GOING TO THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU- MADAM
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS WE JOKE
IN A TIME SERIOUSLY TALK ABOUT
HOW CALIFORNIA IS THE PLACE
WHERE THINGS BEGIN BUT IN THIS
CASE IT'S TRUE WE WEREN'T THE
GAME CHANGER OUR BILL GIVING
STUDENT ATHLETES THE RIGHT TO
EARN MONEY FROM THEIR NAME
IMAGE AND LIKENESS HAS NOW BEEN
COPIED BY TWENTY SIX STATES.
THE US SUPREME COURT RECENTLY
PILED ON AND TOLD THE IN SITU
WAY THAT THEIR MONOPOLISTIC
PLAQUE PRACTICES ARE NO LONGER
LAWFUL ANY NCQA FOLDED ON JULY
FIRST THEY ELIMINATED THEIR
RESTRICTIONS ON NAME IMAGE AND
LIKENESS RIGHTS WE CHANGE THE
WORLD OF COLLEGE SPORTS FOR THE
BETTER WE CHALLENGE THE ON
THEIR EXPLOITATION OF STUDENT
ATHLETES. BUT TODAY WE NEED TO
PASS SB TWENTY SIX. TO ENSURE
THE CALIFORNIA'S NOT
DISADVANTAGED BECAUSE LAWS IN
FOURTEEN OF THE STATES. THAT
COPIED US OR GOING INTO EFFECT
RIGHT NOW. WE ALSO NEED S. B.
TWENTY SIX TO PROTECT THE
RIGHTS OF OUR STUDENT ATHLETES
SO COLLEGES CAN'T MAKE UP THEIR
OWN RULES. AND TO PROTECT OUR-
COLLEGES BECAUSE WE BUILT INTO
THIS LAW PROTECTIONS FOR THE
COLLEGES SO THAT THE STUDENT
ATHLETES COULD NOT TAKE.
CONTRACTS THAT WOULD BE IN
CONFLICT. WITH CONTRACTS THE
COLLEGE HAD. SO THERE ARE TWO
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE TAKEN
SINCE WE'VE SEEN THE BILL ONE
IT'S NOW URGENCY TO IMPLEMENT
R. N. I. L. WRITES ON SEPTEMBER
FIRST. RATHER THAN JANUARY
FIRST AGAIN TWO SO WE ARE NOT
AT A DISADVANTAGE. TO OTHER
STATES. DANTE IT INCLUDES WE'VE
INCLUDED COMMUNITY COLLEGES
NOW. BECAUSE A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE WORKING GROUP.
RECOMMENDED THAT THEY BE
INCLUDED AND THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE UPPORTS. SO OUR HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS THE UC
SYSTEM CS YEARS PRIVATE
COLLEGES LIKE USC AND STANFORD
ARE ALL COMFORTABLE WITH THE
SEPTEMBER FIRST ST. S. B.
TWENTY SIX HAS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT RECEIVED ZERO NO VOTES
PASSING THE ASSEMBLY LAST WEEK
ON A VOTE OF SEVENTY THREE TO
ZERO. THROUGH OUR CREDIT
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN THE
NATIONAL LEADER ON COLLEGE
ATHLETES NAME IMAGE AND
LIKENESS RIGHTS. WE STOOD UP TO
THE NC TWO EIGHT THEY CHANGED
THE RULES LET'S MAINTAIN UR
LEADERSHIP POSITION NATIONALLY.
AND PASSED SB TWENTY SIX TODAY
SENATOR BRADFORD THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT AS JOINT
AUTHOR- WHAT MY COLLEAGUE FROM
BERKELEY OF US FEAT TWENTY SIX
I STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL IS AFFECTIONATELY
KNOWN AS SP TOOLS SIX OUR FAIR
PLAY- FOR PRIDE OF PLACE AT TWO
POINT POLL WHICH WAS THE
RESULTS OF OUR BILLS SENATOR
FROM BERKELEY AND I AUTHORED
TWO YEARS AGO AS B. TWO OLD
SIX. KNOWN AS THE FAIR PLAY TO
PLAY OUT AND AS MY COLLEAGUE
FROM BERKELEY CLEARLY STATED
THAT SAYS CHANGE COLLEGE SPORTS
NOT ONLY HERE IN CALIFORNIA BUT
ACROSS THE NATION THE SUPPORT
YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN THE RIGHT
TO OWN AND THEIR NAME AND IMAGE
AND LIKENESS AND FOR FAR TOO
LONG THESE ATHLETES WERE DENIED
THAT FAR TOO LONG MANY OF THESE
COLLEGE ATHLETES MANY PEOPLE OF
COLOR WENT TO BED HUNGRY WHERE-
WITHOUT THE RESOURCES TO BUY-
SCHOOL EQUIPMENT SEARCHES-
COMPUTERS AND LAB EQUIPMENT FOR
COURSES THAT THEY WERE TAKING-
GO BACK EAST TO PLAY SPORTS. IN
A GAME AND NOT HAVE A WINTER
COLD TO WEAR OF THE SCHOOL FOR
TIM THAT JUST. TWO WEEKS AGO WE
ALL WITNESSED THE OLYMPIC
THAT'S CLEARLY THE
QUINTESSENTIAL AMATEUR-
SUPPORT- THE AROUND THE WORLD
BUT- HOW MANY KNOW THE MAJORITY
OF THOSE ATHLETES THOSE PREMIER
ATHLETES. ARE PAID. THEY ARE
PROFESSIONALS AND THEY'RE
ALLOWED TO COMPETE FOR THEIR
COUNTRIES AND WHAT WAS CLEARLY.
AMATEURISM FOR ALL OVER A-
WOMAN'S TWO HUNDRED YEARS NOW
MOST OF THE ELITE ATHLETES OR
PROFESSIONAL FROM
SKATEBOARDING. TO TEN TO GOLF
TO TRACK AND FIELD MOST OF THEM
ARE MILLIONAIRES BUT THESE
COLLEGE STUDENTS ARE NOT
AFFORDED THIS RIGHT. IN MANY
ARE UNAWARE THAT THE MAJORITY
OF THE ATHLETES LESS THAN 10%
EVER PLAY PROFESSIONAL SPORTS
THEIR TIME TO SHINE IS IN
COLLEGE SO THIS AFFORDS THEM-
THE RIGHT OF ANYONE ELSE TO OWN
THEIR NAME IMAGE AND LIKENESS
AND AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM
BERKELEY SAYS INCLUDES NOW
COMMUNITY COLLEGES BECAUSE
MANY- ATHLETES GET THEIR START
AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE BEFORE
GOING ON TO A FOUR YEAR
UNIVERSITY. SO I WANT TO THANK
MY COLLEAGUES FOR SUPPORTING I
SPEAK TO ALL SIX TWO YEARS AGO
AND- MY COLLEAGUE FROM BERKELEY
WILL TELL YOU WHEN IT LEFT OUR
ASSEMBLY FLOOR SENATE FLOOR AND
ONE OR TWO CERTAINLY WHEN WE
WERE ON SUMMER BREAK. WE WERE
HEAVILY LOBBIED BY THE IN SITU
ES AND UNIVERSITIES HERE IN
THIS STATE AND ACROSS THE
NATION TO PARK THE BILL BUGS
ARE MY COLLEGE IN BERKELEY AND
I PUT OUR HEADS TOGETHER THAT
SUMMER BREAK AND SAYS NO WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE FORWARD AND IT.
LEFT BOTH HOUSES WITHOUT A
SINGLE NO VOTE AND WE WERE ABLE
TO SECURE THE GOVERNOR'S
SIGNATURE WE'RE ASKING FOR THE
SAME THING TODAY THIS IS- HBO
WHOSE TIME HAS COME AND I WAS
ON MY COLLEGE STATED SO GOES
CALIFORNIA SO GOES. THE NATION
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL ANY
FURTHER DISCUSS OR DEBATE THE
SIDE SAYING NON MEMBERS AS A
MEASURE IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS GROW CALLED IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION SEEING NO
OBJECTION I THIRTY FIVE NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES. GOOD WORK
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO ASSEMBLY THIRD READING WE'LL
START WITH ITEM NUMBER FORTY
FOUR SENATOR UMBERG ARE YOU
PREPARED HE IS MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL
FIFTEEN SEVENTY NINE BY THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY
AN ACT RELATING TO FAMILY LAW
SENATOR UMBERG THE FLOOR'S
YOURS THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS- THIS IS THE ASSEMBLY
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE'S ANNUAL
FAMILY LAW OMNIBUS BILL THIS
YEAR BILL ISSUES BILL CORRECTS
INACCURATE CROSS REFERENCES
SENTIMENTS JUST ADDED CHAPTER
IN OUR LANGUAGE THE BILL HAS NO
NO VOTES NO OPPOSITION VERGER
HI BOTH IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SEEING
NONE MEMBERS THIS MEASURE IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL WITHOUT OBJECTION. FIVE
THIRTY FIVE NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS ARE GONNA MOVE
ON TO ITEM NUMBER. FORTY SEVEN.
SENATOR UMBERG THAT IS YOURS AS
WELL MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN
HUNDRED BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CUTTING HIM AN ACT RELATING TO
CRIMINAL PROCEDURE. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS- I'M
PRESENTING A B. SEVEN HUNDRED
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CUTTING HIM CURRENTLY
DEFENDANTS IN FELONY CASES A
GENERAL PART BE PERSONALLY
PRESENT DURING TRIAL OR
PRELIMINARY EXAMINATION HOWEVER
IN CERTAIN INSTANCES A TRIAL
CAN PROCEED IN DEFENDANT'S
ABSENCE. UNDER CURRENT LAW THE
DEFENDANT MAY BE ABSENT AFTER
THE TRIAL OR PRELIMINARY
EXAMINATIONS COMMENCED IN THEIR
PRESENCE THIS CREATES A PROBLEM
IN SCENARIOS WHERE DEFENDANTS
IN CUSTODY OR NOT PRESENT FOR
THE COMMENCEMENT OF TRIAL OR
PRELIMINARY EXAMINATION. THIS
BECOME A MAJOR ISSUE DURING THE
CALL THAT NINETEEN PANDEMIC AB
SEVEN HUNDRED WOULD ALLOW A
PRELIMINARY EXAMINATION OR TRY
OUT TO SEE DEFENDANTS ABSENCE
UNDER CERTAIN VERY NARROW
CONDITIONS ONE THE DEFENDANT IS
IN CUSTODY TO THE COURT MAKES
CERTAIN FINDINGS INCLUDING THAT
THERE IS. CLEAR AND CONVINCING
EVIDENCE THE DEFENDANTS
VOLUNTARILY CHOOSING NOT TO
APPEAR IN COURT AND THREE
DEFENDANTS REPRESENTED BY
COUNSEL WHO IS PRESENT DEFENSE-
THE DEFENDANT HAS VOLUNTARILY
CONSENTED COMMENCING THE
PROCEEDINGS UNDER. AFTER BEING
INFORMED OF. THEIR RIGHTS.
ORIGIN I BOUGHT ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE SIDE OF SEEING
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE MEMBERS
THIS ITEM IS ALSO ELIGIBLE FOR
A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION SEEING NO
OBJECTIONS I CERTIFIED NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS ARE
GONNA MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER
FIFTY ONE. SENATOR GORGEOUS.
ARE YOU PREPARED HE IS NO. OKAY
WE WILL PASS ON IT WILL JUST
GIVE HIM A SECOND. HE IS
PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY JOINT RESOLUTION
TWELVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER STONE
RELATIVE TO VETERANS
EDUCATIONAL BENEFITS SENATOR
BURGESS THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
COLLEAGUES I RISE TO PRESENT
TODAY J. R. TWELVE RESOLUTIONS
URGING CONGRESS TO RESTORE GI
FUNDING ELIGIBILITY TO
CALIFORNIA ACCREDITED LAW
SCHOOLS AS PART OF FEDERAL
LEGISLATION RECENTLY
IMPLEMENTED THE POST NINE
ELEVEN GI BILL WAS AMENDED TO
REQUIRE IN ORDER TO RECEIVE GI
BILL FUNDS THAT ALL LAW SCHOOLS
MUST BE ACCREDITED BY THE
AMERICAN BAR ASSOCIATION. AND
THEY GRADUATES MUST BE ELIGIBLE
TO SIT FOR THE BAR EXAMINATION
IN ANY STATE THIS FEDERAL
LEGISLATION DOES NOT IMPACT THE
BA CREDIT LAW SCHOOLS IN IN
CALIFORNIA IT ALSO DOES NOT
IMPACT MOST LAW SCHOOLS IN
OTHER STATES THAT ARE NOT A BIG
CREDIT. HOWEVER IT IS A
SIGNIFICANT IN SEVERE IMPACT IN
CALIFORNIA. BECAUSE IT CUTS OFF
GI BILL FUNDS TO VETERANS
WISHING TO STUDY IN A
CALIFORNIA ACCREDITED LAW
SCHOOLS THESE LAW SCHOOLS WHICH
ARE REGULATED BY THE CALIFORNIA
STATE BAR OFFER VETERANS
GREATER FLEXIBILITY. IN GETTING
THEIR LEGAL EDUCATION OPERATE
IN MANY RURAL AREAS THAT ARE
FAR FROM MAYBE A CREDIT LAW
SCHOOLS. SUCH AS SALINAS
BAKERSFIELD FRESNO AND SO ON.
SERVE AREAS WITH MINORITY
POPULATIONS IN OFTEN COST A
FRACTION OF WHAT AMERICAN BAR
ASSOCIATION ACCREDITED LAW
SCHOOLS COST SOME OF THESE
CALIFORNIA ACCREDITED LAW
SCHOOLS ALSO HAVE A HIGHER A
HIGHER BAR PASSAGE RATE THAN
SOME OF THE AMERICAN BAR
ASSOCIATION ACCREDITED SCHOOLS.
AJ ARE TWELVE CALLS UPON
CONGRESS TO RECOGNIZE THE
CALIFORNIA ACCREDITED LAW
SCHOOLS PROVIDE A VALUABLE
OPPORTUNITY LAW SCHOOL OPTION
FOR VETERANS AND THEIR ELIGIBLE
DEPENDENTS WROTE CITY
CALIFORNIA FOR DECADES. IN
SHORT THIS RESOLUTION URGES
CONGRESS TO RECONSIDER
AMENDMENTS TO THE GI BILL. THE
CALIFORNIA VETERANS WHO WISH TO
RECEIVE ALLEGED LEGAL EDUCATION
AT CALIFORNIA CREDIT LAW
SCHOOLS ARE ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE
GI BILL EDUCATIONAL BENEFITS.
THIS RESOLUTION IS RECEIVE
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT IN BOTH
HOUSES COLLEAGUES URGE YOU TO
SEND. ALSO UNANIMOUS AND
BIPARTISAN MESSAGE TO CONGRESS
WITHIN A VOTE ON AJ R. TWELVE
TO ENSURE THAT VETERANS WISHING
TO ATTEND CALIFORNIA ACCREDITED
LAW SCHOOLS CAN CONTINUE TO
ACCESS THEIR GI BILL FUNDS
SENATOR CHILLIN THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I RISE IN SUPPORT AND
AJ ARE TWELVE. THIS MORNING WE
HONORED OUR FLAG WITH THE MEN
AND WOMEN SERVING IN
AFGHANISTAN AND ACROSS THE
WORLD. WE ALSO HAVE TO HONOR
THEM TO BE ABLE TO GIVE THEM A
SENSE OF PRIDE AND DIGNITY TO
COME HOME TO CALIFORNIA TO
CONTINUE THEIR EDUCATION AND
ONE DAY ASPIRE TO BE AN
ATTORNEY AND TO GO TO A LAW
SCHOOL CLOSE TO THEIR HOME
TOWN. CLOSE TO THEIR FAMILIES
THEY NEED THAT ABILITY TO DO
THAT AND TO BE ABLE TO DO THIS
I THINK THIS IS THE RIGHT STEP
AND I HOPE THAT WE ALL JOINED
IN SUPPORTING HR TWELVE. AND I
URGE AND I BOTH IS THERE ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM SAYING NINE
MEMBERS THIS IS THIS MEASURE IS
ELIGIBLE FOR A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION.
SAYING NONE HIGHS THIRTY FIVE
NO ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. REMEMBER WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER SEVENTY
TWO. SENATOR NELSON HE IS READY
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GALLAGHER AN ACT
RELATING TO PUBLIC CONTRACTS
SENATOR NIELSEN THE FLOOR'S
YOURS MADAM PRESIDENT LAYS DOWN
THE SENATE THIS IS ANOTHER STEP
ALONG THE WAY OF THE PARADISE
COME BACK. THAT CITY TWENTY TWO
THOUSAND PEOPLE VIEWED COUNTY
TOTALLY DESTROYED IN THE FIRE
ADDRESSES AN ISSUE THAT GOES
BACK A THIRTY SOME YEARS THAT
BEING A SEWAGE LINE IT WOULD BE
ABLE TO ADDRESS THE SEWAGE
ISSUES OF PARADISE THAT WOULD
CARRY THAT EFFLUENT DOWN INTO
THE CHICO AREA FOR THEIR SEWAGE
TREATMENT PLANT THIS BILL WOULD
ALLOW DESIGN BUILD FOR THIS
PROJECT GREATLY EXPEDITING THE
PROJECT WHICH IS REALLY
CRITICAL TO HAVE THAT COMMUNITY
TO BE ABLE TO COME BACK TO BE
SELF SUFFICIENT AGAIN ALSO A
WATER PIPELINE THERE'S ANOTHER
CRITICAL PROJECT FOR PARADOX
NOT ENOUGH WATER UP ON THE HILL
AND- THEY THEY WE DO HAVE A
LAKE UP THERE BUT THERE'S JUST
NOT ENOUGH AND THIS IS GOING TO
BE HELPFUL AND THE REAL PROBLEM
IS WITH THE PARADISE YOUR
NATION DISTRICT WITH THE FIRE
THEY LOST FOR MUCH OF THE
REVENUE FOR THAT IRRIGATION
DISTRICT THIS IS ANOTHER PART
AND PARCEL OF THAT COME BACK IT
WOULD FACILITATE THE
CONSTRUCTION OF THESE VERY
NEEDED INFRASTRUCTURE
FACILITIES AND THE SIGN
BUILDERS WELL ESTABLISHED AND
WELL PROVEN ACCOMPLISH
EXPEDITIOUS THOROUGH AND VERY
SAFE PROJECTS I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AVAILABLE IS THERE
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SAYING
NONE MEMBERS THIS IS ALSO
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
UTILIZING THAT SEEING NONE ICE
THIRTY FIVE NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS GOING TO MOVE ON
TO ITEM NUMBER SEVENTY SEVEN
SENATOR PAN IS READY MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL THREE FORTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIPSON AN ACT
RELATING TO HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE CENTER POUND THE FLOOR
IS YOURS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT SENATORS ON BEHALF OF
THE SEVEN MEMBER GIBSON I
WRITES PERCENT EIGHTY THREE
FORTY TWO WHICH SEEKS TO REMOVE
COST BARRIERS FOR PATIENTS IN
NEED CALL AND ASK YOU PLEASE
FOR COLON CANCER SCREENING.
REMOVING THESE BARRIERS WILL
HELP CATCH CASES OF COLORECTAL
CANCER EARLIER IMPROVING
SURVIVAL RATES COLORECTAL
CANCER IS THE SECOND HIGHEST
CAUSE OF CANCER DEATHS IN
AMERICA IN THE THIRD MOST
COMMON CAUSE OF CANCER IN MEN
AND WOMEN THIS CANCER'S ABILITY
PREVENTABLE WITH SCREENING AND
EARLY DETECTION. HOWEVER WE
NEED TO ENSURE THAT. PEOPLE ARE
HAVE ACCESS TO COLIN OSCAR BEES
IN ITS COVERAGE SO THIS BILL
REMOVES THAT BARRIER FOR
SENIORS IN MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES WHO CAN AFFORD THE
CARE THEY NEED. LEAVE THEM AT
RISK FOR PEVENTABLE DEATH THIS
BILL IS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT I STRICTLY AS PER NIGHT
THAT IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SEEING
NONE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ALAN ARCHULETA HI
AT KANSAS BATES BACKER. HI
FORGES ARE YOU BRADFORD I COME
BY ADAM HI COURTESY I DALLY
DODD THERE ARE SO FIVE EGGMAN I
GLAZER FIVE CONSOLIDATES HIGH
GROWTH HI HERTZBERG WHAT'S SO
HI HER TADO HI JONES I CAN
LONGER I LAYERED FIVE LLEVA
FIVE THE MON FIVE MCGUIRE I
MELINDA'S MAN HI NIMIN NIELSEN
I A SHOW OF BOTH. TEN FIVE
FOURTEEN TINA I BROUGHT HI
RUBIO HI SKINNER HI STERN I AM
BERG I FORECASTING WEINER I
WILL. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ALAN I AT KINS BATES
DALLY I GOD HERTZBERG MELINDA'S
NEWMAN THE TROUBLE WHITE HOUSE
SKI WELK. FIVE THIRTY ONE NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBER EIGHTY THREE
SENATOR LEYVA MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL SIX
SIXTEEN BY FAMILY MEMBERS DOWN
AN ACT RELATING TO LABOR
RELATIONS CENTER LEVEL FLOORS
YOURS THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
GOOD AFTERNOON OR GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS IT IS MY PLEASURE TO
PRESENT TO YOU TODAY A. B. SIX
ONE SIX. MEMBERS WHEN EACH OF
US VOTES HERE IN CALIFORNIA
THERE ARE SEVERAL WAYS TO DO
THAT SOME OF US WILL GO TO THE
POLLS TO CAST HER BALLOT.
OTHERS WILL MAIL IT IN SOME
CALIFORNIANS WILL NEED HELP
FILLING OUT THEIR BALLOT WELL
OTHERS OF US WILL DROP IT OFF
BEFORE ELECTION DAY. WE HAVE
CHOICES THE CALIFORNIA VOTING
CHOICE ACT GAVE US THOSE
CHOICES CHOICES THAT DID NOT
EXIST IN NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE
WHEN CALIFORNIA GAVE FARM
WORKERS THE RIGHT TO VOTE IN
UNION REPRESENTATION ELECTIONS.
MEMBERS AV SIX ONE SIX IS THE
AGRICULTURAL LABOR RELATIONS
VOTING CHOICE ACT. IT
MODERNIZES SECRET BALLOT
ELECTIONS FOR FARM WORKERS BY
GIVING THEM OPPORTUNITIES TO
VOTE TO MANY OF THE SAME WAYS
THAT EACH OF US HAVE WHEN WE
VOTE MEMBERS RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AND I THOUGHT THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM SENATOR DR. THANK YOU- I
RISE TO SUPPORT- A. B. SIX ONE
SIX- THROUGHOUT THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS SOME OPPONENTS OF THIS
BILL HAVE ASSERTED THAT. THIS
IS ACTUALLY A CARD CHECK. BUT
LET'S PUT ASIDE THE FACT THAT
THAT'S NOT TRUE AND I JUST WANT
YOU TO CONSIDER ONE OTHER
ISSUE. PUBLIC EMPLOYEES IN
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
FIREFIGHTERS POLICE OFFICERS
HOME CARE WORKERS CLERKS
RESEARCHERS WHETHER THEY WORK
FOR THE STATE A CITY COUNTY OR
SPECIAL DISTRICT EVERY
CALIFORNIAN UNDER THE
JURISDICTION OF THE PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT RELATIONS BOARD HAS
HAD THE RIGHT TO JOIN A UNION
BY USING A CARD CHECK PROCESS
SINCE TWENTY TWELVE. SO IF BY
CHANCE YOU THINK THAT THE CAR
CHECK IS DEFACTO DENIAL OF A
SECRET BALLOT THEN WOULD YOU
REALLY WANT TO REPEAL THAT
RIGHT THAT'S ALL I'M ASKING IS
PLEASE DON'T USE THIS
INFORMATION HAS BEEN CIRCULATED
TO TRY AND JUSTIFY VOTING
AGAINST A. B. SIX ONE SIX I
SINCERELY. HOPE YOU VOTE AND
SUPPORT THIS URGENT LIBEL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH CENTER GROVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT- THE F. W. THE AUTHOR
AND THE FLOOR MANAGER OF THIS
BILL OF ARGUING THAT THIS
DOESN'T TAKE AWAY THE WORKERS
RIGHT TO SECRET BALLOT- AND
THAT THE BILL WOULD NOT ALLOW
FOR A UNION MEMBER TO FILL OUT
THE BALLOT ON BEHALF OF THE
WORKER IN TURN IT IN. BUT I'D
LIKE TO DIRECT YOU TO THE
LANGUAGE- IN THE CODE SECTION
ONE ONE FIVE SIX POINT THREE
FIVE AC THREE THE SIGNATURE OF
THE PERSON WITNESSING THAT THE
EMPLOYEE SIGNED THE BALLOT CARD
OR ASSISTING THEM TO FILL IT
OUT OR THE BALLOT CARD OR BOTH
AND THEN ON SECTION FOUR
THERE'S A SECTION IN THERE THAT
SAYS THE BALLOT CARD SHALL BE
SUBMITTED DIRECTLY TO THE
OFFICE OF THEBOARD IN AN
ENVELOPE PROVIDED BY THE BOARD
OR MAIL TO THE BOARD OFFICE- IN
IN THAT CAN BE PROVIDED- BY AN
INDIVIDUAL THAT'S COLLECTING
THAT BALLOT THIS. BILL CONCERNS
ME DRASTICALLY WE HAVE THE TOP
THREE AGRICULTURE PRODUCING
COUNTIES IN THE WORLD WE ALL
KNOW THAT FARM WORKERS. ARE
ESSENTIAL COG IN THE WHEEL IN
ORDER TO CREATE FOOD SECURITY.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT BY
REPLACING THE CURRENT WAY THAT
EMPLOYEES ARE EXCUSE ME THAT
THAT FARM WORKERS VOTE BY
SECRET BALLOT. TOO MUCH LESS
PRIVATE REPRESENTATION- AND
APPORTION. AND PLEASE DON'T BE
NAIVE TO THINK THAT THINGS LIKE
THIS DON'T HAPPEN. THEY CAN BE
PRESSURED BULLIED AND EVEN
ATTACKED BY U. S. W. AND THEIR
MEMBERS. WE WITNESS THIS FIRST
HAND WITH THE BATTLE BETWEEN
THE GRAMMAR AND FARM WORKERS
AND THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THE
LRB IN THE U. F. W. I CAN TELL
YOU THAT YEARS. SIX YEARS. OF
GATHERING SIGNATURES ON
PETITIONS BY SYLVIA LOPEZ AT A
LOCAL FARM WORKER IN OUR
COMMUNITY. THAT TIME WAS NOT
INTIMIDATING SHE'S ALL OF FIVE
FEET TALL. SHE WENT OUT AND
GATHERED SIGNATURES OF PEOPLE
TO DECERTIFY THE U. F. W.
WANTED TWENTY YEAR ELECTION THE
DID NOT- EVEN TAKE PART IN THE
TWENTY YEARS THAT THEY WERE.
ASSESSED TO HAVE THE CONTRACT.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT THE
SIGNATURE PROCESS WAS D. SIR-
DISMISSED TWICE BY THE
ADMINISTRATION THE LRB. I CAN
TELL YOU THAT COURT CASES AFTER
COURT CASES AND FINALLY A
CERTIFIED ELECTION. THAT WAS
TAKEN AND OVERSIGHT SEEN BY
THEN. THE D. I. R.THE
ADMINISTRATION THE CURRENT D.
I. R. V. IN THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION THAT SHE WAS ON
THE GROUND THERE AND EVEN THAT
ELECTION THE ADMINISTRATION
LOCKED UP THOSE BALLOTS FOR
FIVE YEARS BEFORE THOSE VOTES
COULD EVEN BE COUNTED DURING
THAT FIVE YEAR PROCESS FARM
WORKERS WERE ATTACKED THEIR
TIRES WERE SLASHED THEIR CARS
WERE KEYED THEIR HOMES WERE
VANDALIZED AND THEIR CHILDREN
WERE STOCKED WHEN THEY WENT TO
SCHOOL. I CAN TELL YOU THAT
THESE THINGS ARE REAL AND IT
HAPPENS TO ELIMINATE OR TO NOT
JUST ALLOW A SECRET BALLOT VOTE
SO THAT PEOPLE COULD KEEP THEIR
VOTE PRIVATE JUST LIKE WE DO IN
THE ELECTION PROCESS WE KEEP
OUR VOTE PRIVATE YOU WALK INTO
THAT VOTING BOOTH YOU MAIL YOUR
BALLOT- ALL THE WAYS THAT WE
HAVE THE ABILITY TO VOTE IT'S
ALL PRIVATE. AND WE CAN'T HAVE
PEOPLE ASSIST US IF WE NEED
ASSISTANCE BUT YOU STILL RETAIN.
HARVESTING I CAN TELL YOU AFTER
SIX YEARS OF A COURT BATTLE THE
VICTORY CAME TO THE FARM
WORKERS WHEN THE BALLOTS WERE
FINALLY COUNTED AFTER A JUDGE
ORDERED THEM TO BE COUNTED
COUNTED AND THE VOTE WAS ONE
THOUSAND NINETY EIGHT FOR THE
ELIMINATION OF THE OF THE-
UNION CONTRACT BY SECRET BALLOT
AND A HUNDRED AND NINETY SEVEN.
TO KEEP IT AND I CAN TELL YOU
THAT THE SIX YEARS THAT THESE
FARM WORKERS WERE IT WAITED FOR
JUSTICE WAS JUST HORRENDOUS ON
THEM AND THEIR PERSONAL LIVES I
AM GETTING A CROSS PICKET LINES
EVERY SINGLE DAY FROM FARM
WORKERS THAT WERE- PEOPLE THAT
WERE NOT REALLY FARM WORKERS
THAT WERE PAID TO BE THERE- IN
PAID ON THE SIDELINES. IT'S
JUST HORRENDOUS AND I THINK
THAT PUTTING OUR FARM WORKERS
IN JEOPARDY IS JUST ONE REASON
THIS BIT THIS BILL SHOULD NOT
PASS AGAIN OUR FARM WORKERS ARE
AN INTEGRAL COG IN THE WHEEL
FOR OUR FOOD SECURITY AND
DEVELOPMENT OF FOOD PRODUCTS
AND TO PUT THEM UNDER THIS TYPE
OF PRESSURE. COUNTLESS FARM
WORKERS IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
OR NOT FOR THIS AND I WOULD ASK
YOUR NO VOTE SENATOR GLACIER.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY- WITH- I
DEEP CONCERNS ABOUT THIS BILL
THAT'S BEFORE YOU NOW. IT'S
EASY TO- CHARACTERIZE THE
DEBATE TODAY AS PRO UNION OR
ANTI UNION AND I DON'T THINK
IT'S ANYTHING OF THE KIND. IF
THE BILL BEFORE US WAS ABOUT
HOW WE CAN PROTECT THE RIGHT OF
THE UNIONS FOR FAIR AND FREE
ELECTIONS. OF OUR AGRICULTURAL
WORKERS I'D BE STANDING WITH
ALL THOSE WHO WANT TO ENSURE
THAT WE PROTECT THOSE RIGHTS.
BUT THAT'S THAT'S NOT THE ISSUE
THAT'S BEFORE US TODAY AND I
ASK YOU THIS QUESTION IF THIS
BILL IN ITS CURRENT FORM WAS
BEFORE YOU AND GAVE THE SAME
RIGHTS IN THAT BILL TO THE
EMPLOYER THAT THEY COULD
CIRCULATE A PETITION THAT THEY
COULD GET A SECRET BALLOT IN
THIS FORMAT THAT'S PROVIDED FOR
THIS BILL TO DECERTIFY A UNION
WOULD YOU SUPPORT THAT
LEGISLATION SAME RULES BUT NOW
WE'RE GOING TO APPLY IT TO THE
EMPLOYER NOT JUST TO. THE
EMPLOYEE FOR THE FOLKS WHO WANT
TO REPRESENT THE EMPLOYEE AND I
WOULD SUGGEST YOU THAT MANY OF
YOU WOULD HAVE GRAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT ALLOWING FOR THE
DECERTIFICATION OF A UNION
UNDER THOSE TERMS. WE SPEND A
LOT OF TIME IN THIS CHAMBER.
PROTECTING THE SANCTITY OF THE
BALLOT BOX. IN PREVIOUS YEARS
AND CERTAINLY THIS YEAR YOU'LL
SEE AND HEAR AND PASS MANY
BILLS PROTECTING THE RIGHT OF
THE BALLOT BOX THE SECRET
BALLOT MAKING SURE THAT- VOTER
CAN CAST THEIR VIEWS- WITH
PROTECTIONS. BUT I SUGGEST TO
YOU THAT THE BILL BEFORE YOU
WOULD ELIMINATE THAT ASSESS FOR
FARM WORKERS YOU CAN HAVE AN
ELECTION WHERE THERE ARE FOLKS
THAT WE ARE PART OF THE AT THE
REPRESENTED CLASS THAT'S BEING
PROPOSED THAT WOULD NOT EVEN BE
ABLE TO VOTE IN THE ELECTION
DOESN'T REQUIRE THAT EVERYBODY
GET A BALLOT IT'S A SELECTIVE
GROUP THEY CAN GET A BALLOT.
AND WHETHER IT'S DONE BY A
UNION OR THE EMPLOYER I THINK
WE SHOULD HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
THAT. WILLIAM GOULD WHO IS-
PROFESSOR EMERITUS AT STANFORD
LAW SCHOOL AND FORMER CHAIRMAN
OF THE AGRICULTURAL LABOR
RELATIONS BOARD I WROTE A PIECE
ABOUT THIS LEGISLATION AND- THE
IT'S CAPTURED IN THE HEADLINE
FARMWORKERS DESERVE DEMOCRATIC
PROTECTIONS. AND HE GOES ON TO
SAY IN THE IN THE IN THE PIECE
THAT THE AGRICULTURAL LABOR
RELATIONS BOARD IS THE
APPROPRIATE NEUTRAL PARTY TO
HANDLE THIS RESPONSIBILITY NOT
PRIVATE PARTIES SINCE. WE HAVE
A PROCESS TO ENSURE FAIR
ELECTIONS IN OUR FIELDS. WE
WANT TO HAVE FAIR ELECTIONS. IN
THE FIELDS BUT WE HAVE TO DO IT
THE RIGHT WAY. I THINK THAT THE
BILL BEFORE US AS THE BEST OF
INTENTIONS BUT IT DOES IT IN A
WAY THAT UNDERCUTS OUR
DEMOCRATIC VALUES OF FEDERAL
ACTIONS FOR EVERYONE NOT JUST
THE SELECTED FEW AND MEMBERS
WANT TO GET THIS BILL WAS
BEFORE YOU GIVEN THE SAME
RIGHTS TO THE EMPLOYER TO
DECERTIFY I THINK WE WOULD ALL
HAVE THE SAME CONCERNS THAT OF
EXPRESSING HERE TODAY
ACCORDINGLY I WOULD RECOMMEND A
NO VOTE ON A. B. SIX SIXTEEN.
SENATOR BURGESS. MADAM
PRESIDENT I THINK MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE BEEN BROUGHT UP SOME VERY
IMPORTANT POINTS SO I WON'T.
RECITE. THEM IN TOO MUCH DETAIL
THIS IS A FAIRLY SIMPLE ISSUE
FOR MANY YEARS WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT- VOTER PROTECTION
IN FRANCHISE MEANT WHAT IT
MEANS FOR OUR TO OUR TO OUR
AMERICAN SYSTEM OR OR FORM OF
REPRESENTATIVE GOVERNMENT IF
YOU BELIEVE IN VOTER PROTECTION
IN THE SANCTITY OF THE VOTE
DISCLOSING AND CREATING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR INDIVIDUALS
TO BE INFLUENCE INTIMIDATED
THREATENED THAT'S ANATHEMA TO
WHAT WE STAND FOR. SO
COLLEAGUES- I'D HAVE TO AGREE
WITH THE FORMER PRESENTER THIS
IS NOT A FULLY BAKED IDEA IT
DESERVES A LOT MORE REVIEW A
LOT MORE EXAMINATION BECAUSE I
THINK THERE COULD BE SOME PASS
FORWARD BUT UNDER ITS CURRENT
FORM THIS IS AN ON DEMOCRATIC
PIECE OF PROPOSED LEGISLATION
AND I WOULD STRONGLY ENCOURAGE
A NO VOTE. AND ASK THE AUTHOR
TO REVISIT THIS WITH MORE
INDIVIDUALS- AT THE TABLE MORE
STAKEHOLDERS- TO FIGURE OUT HOW
TO PROTECT THE PEOPLE'S RIGHT
TO VOTE AND TO VOTE SAFELY.
SENATOR NIELSEN OKAY MADAM
PRESIDENT LAYS DOWN ON THE
SENATE HIRED YOUR NO VOTE AND
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT I HAVE
DEALT WITH SINCE THE NINETEEN
SEVENTIES IT'S BEEN AROUND
AGAIN AND AGAIN AND AGAIN NOW
YOU DON'T IF YOU WANT TO USE ME
FOR MYSTICALLY NOT CALL A CARD
CHECK THAT'S OKAY BUT IT IS NOT
DEMOCRATIC IT ALLOWS AN
INTERMEDIATE PARTY A PARTISAN
PARTY TO INTERFERE IN THE
PROCESS THE AGRICULTURAL LABOR
RELATIONS BOARD WAS SET UP
DECADES AGO TO COULD THE
MINISTER THE SELECTION IT FOR
THE FARM WORKERS AND THE
DESERTIFICATION ELECTIONS AS
WELL AS THE ELECTIONS FOR
REPRESENTATION AND I'VE SEEN
THE ABUSE OF THIS VOTING METHOD
OVER THE YEARS UPFRONT AND
PERSONAL ON THE LINE WHERE
THESE ELECTIONS WERE BEING ARE
THESE CARDS WERE BEING
COLLECTED THIS IS NOT
DEMOCRATIC THIS IS A VERY
PARTISAN WAY ARE NOT PARTISAN
WAY BUT A VERY SELF INTERESTED
WAY. TO ENHANCE REALLY ONE
UNION WHO HAS NOT BEEN
SUCCESSFUL OVER DECADES AND
PROVIDING GOOD SERVICES TO
THEIR WORKERS THAT THEY
REPRESENT THEIR NUMBERS HAVE
NEVER GROWN IT'S NEVER BEEN A
UNION THE PROSPECT IT'S A GOOD
CAUSE AND THEY'RE IN WHAT HAS
BEEN THEIR SUCCESS BUT IN TERMS
OF GETTING EMPLOYEES BARM
WORKERS TO JOIN THE UNION THE
ALLEN WANTED TO. THAT UNION HAS
LANGUISHEDIN DIFFERENT PRODUCT
UP BY FEDERAL FUNDS OVER THE
YEARS AND BY LEGISLATION OVER
THE YEARS HERE'S ANOTHER
EXAMPLE WHAT YOU'RE DOING IS
PROPPING UP ONE UNION. SENATOR
CORTESE. THANK YOU- THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT I RISE IN SUPPORT
OF SB SIX ONE SIX- AS A TEACHER
OF THE SENATE LABOR PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT AND RETIREMENT
COMMITTEE- I WANT TO. MAKE SURE
TO- GET THE STATEMENT ON THE
FOREIGN ON THE RECORD THAT THIS
BILL WAS VETTED THOROUGHLY BY
COMMITTEE STAFF- BETTER
THOROUGHLY BY THE COMMITTEE
ITSELF I GOT OUT OF THE
COMMITTEE ON A FOUR TO ONE
VOTE. IN ALL THE ISSUES THAT
I'VE HEARD RAISED TODAY- HAVE
BEEN ADDRESSED. THIS BILL IF
YOU LOOK AT THE LANGUAGE IN THE
BILL ANALYSIS REQUIRES THESE
BALLOTS THAT WERE REFERRED TO
BE SEALED IN ENVELOPES. AND
SIGNED UP BY THE ACTUAL
EMPLOYEE. OF THEY CAN BE
DELIVERED BY SOMEONE ELSE- NOT.
UNLIKE WHAT VOTERS WILL BE
DOING THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
IN THE UPCOMING ELECTION AND
MOST UPCOMING ELECTIONS- NOT
UNLIKELY TO SOLUTION THAT WE'VE
ADOPTED HERE. IN THE
LEGISLATURE TO ALLOW RANK AND
FILE VOTERS IN CALIFORNIA- TO
PUT THEIR BALLOTS IN ENVELOPES.
AND SEAL THEM. SIGN THEM- AND
THEN HAVE THOSE ENVELOPES
DESTROYED BEFORE COUNTING OR
SET ASIDE. SO THAT THE BALLOT
ITSELF REMAINS SECRET- THINK
CAN BE DELIVERED BY THIRD PARTY
AGAIN. MUCH LIKE WE DO WITH
CALIFORNIA ELECTION LAW- I
THINK THE BILL IS SOLID. I'M A
LITTLE SURPRISED TO SOME DEGREE
OTHER THAN- THE OBVIOUS
CONCERNS THAT THE FOLKS WOULD
HAVE WHO ARE AGAINST ORGANIZED
IN THE FIRST PLACE. WHY
AGRICULTURAL INTERESTS YOU KNOW
SPENT SOME TIME IN THAT SPACE-
WOULD WANT THE DISRUPTION. OF
THESE ELECTIONS GOING ON ON
SITE- WITHOUT THE ABILITY OF
PUTTING BALLOTS AND ENVELOPES
IN GATHERING THEM REMOTELY AND
GETTING THEM DELIVERED- IN IN
AN EFFICIENT. MANNER AND IN A
MANNER THAT REALLY SPEAKS TO
THE SAME EFFICACY THAT WE HAVE
IN OUR ELECTION PROCESS IN THE
SAME LACK OF CONSTRAINTS THAT
WE HAVE. IN THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WITH OUR OWN.
ELECTIONS COLLECTION PROCESSES
SO I STRONGLY. URGE AND I VOTE
ON THIS BILL THANK YOU SENATOR
TIGHTER THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES MANY OF
YOU KNOW THAT. MY PARENTS WERE
FORMER OCCURS AND I USED TO BE
A LABOR ORGANIZER FOR SEVERAL
YEARS- AND ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I NOTICED AS AN ORGANIZER-
TRYING TO RECRUIT MEMBERSHIP
INTO A UNION IS THAT-
INDIVIDUALS HAD TO UNDERSTAND
THE VALUE OF HAVING A UNION.
TELLING THEM OR EVEN SENDING A
BALLOT DOESN'T DEMONSTRATE THE
VALUE OF THE UNION NOT TO SAY
THAT THERE ISN'T ANY OTHER
BECAUSE THERE IS A LOT OF VALUE
IN HAVING MILLIONS IN THE
WORKPLACES- I'LL TELL YOU THAT
I'VE ALSO MET THIS WEEKEND WITH
FARMERS. AND I WILL TELL YOU
THAT THE LAST THING ON THEIR
MIND IS WHETHER OR NOT TO JOIN
THE UNION RIGHT NOW THE ONE
MAIN CONCERN ON THEIR MIND IS
WATER BECAUSE IF THEY DON'T
HAVE ANY WATER THEY DON'T HAVE
A JOB AND THIS BILL CAN MAKE
ITS WAY THROUGH AND IT IT IT
I'M SURE THE DEAN THE
INTENTIONS OF THE BILL. I SEEK
TO DO GOOD FOR FARM WORKERS
THERE'S NO DOUBT IN MY MIND
ABOUT THAT. HOWEVER BY THE TIME
IT GETS THERE. WILL BE
THOUSANDS OF FARM WORKERS
WITHOUT JOBS THE FARMWORKERS
NEED ACTION RIGHT NOW AND- I
HAVE SEVERAL CONCERNS WITH THE
SPELL LIKE I SAID IF YOU WANT
TO DO SOMETHING FOR FARM
WORKERS THEY NEED WATER. THEY
NEED OPPORTUNITIES AND- FOR ALL
THESE REASONS I'LL BE. STAYING
OFF THE SPOT TODAY IS THERE ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. SINGMAN SENATOR
LABOR YOU MAY CONCLUDE THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT OF WHAT A
LOT OF THINGS TO UNPACK HERE TO
THE SENATOR FROM SANGER DO NOT
CONFUSE THIS ISSUE WE DO
UNDERSTAND THAT FARM WORKERS
NEED WATER AND JUST BECAUSE
THEY MAY NOT VOTE FOR UNION
TODAY THEY MIGHT NEED THAT
RIGHT AND HAVE IT IN PLACE
TOMORROW OR IN THE FUTURE SO
YOU COULD STILL VOTE YES ON
THIS BILL AND WE COULD STILL DO
SOMETHING FOR THEM. AND THEIR
GUARDS TO WATER TO MY COLLEAGUE
FROM BAKERSFIELD I KNOW THAT
YOU OWN A TEMPORARY WORKER
AGENCY I DID NOT KNOW YOU HAD
SO MUCH EXPERTISE IN ORGANIZING
WORKERS I WANT TO ASSURE YOU
THAT IN THIS PARTICULAR BILL.
YOUR BALANCE IS KEPT SECRET.
UNLESS SOMEONE HELPS YOU THAT
IS NOT KEPT SECRET SO WE'RE NOT
TAKING AWAY ANYONE'S RIGHT HERE
TO MY COLLEAGUE WHO REFERRED TO
MR GOLD'S PEAS MR GOLD PIECE
WAS MISLEADING AND IT WAS AN
ACCURATE AT BEST MEMBERS WHEN I
LOOK AT MY COLLEAGUE FROM LOS
ANGELES WHO ORGANIZED FOR AS
MANY OR MORE YEARS THAN I DID.
WE KNOW IT'S NOT UNION
INTIMIDATION WE KNOW THAT IT IS
PLACES LIKE HOME DEPOT WALMART
CORPORATIONS WHO WILL SPEND
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS. WITH ANTI
UNION RHETORIC IN CAMPAIGNS TO
KEEP THE UNION OUT WE KNOW THAT
IN SMALLER VENUES WITH SMALLER
EMPLOYERS. THEY DO DIFFERENT
THINGS I REMEMBER WHEN WE WERE
TRYING TO ORGANIZE A MACARONI
PLANT IN CHINO ORLANDO'S
MACARONI THE EMPLOYERS CAME IN
THE NIGHT BEFORE THE ELECTION
AND GAVE EVERYONE A THOUSAND
DOLLAR BONUS AND WHAT I SAID TO
THOSE WORKERS AS I SAID TAKE
THAT MONEY AND VOTE FOR THE
UNION TO. A SET BECAUSE DID
THEY EVER GIVE YOU A ONE
THOUSAND DOLLAR BONUS PRIOR TO
YOU WANTING TO FORM A UNION. NO
THEY DID NOT THE CARDS ARE
ALWAYS STACKED AGAINST THE
WORKER WHO IS TRYING TO FORM A
UNION. TO HAVE A MORE JUST AND
FAIR WORKPLACE. THIS BILL IS
SIMPLE MY FRIENDS THIS BILL IS
ABOUT ALLOWING A DIFFERENT
OPTION. FOR FARM WORKERS TO
VOTE. MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN ARCHULETA
HI ATKINS. EIGHT NO BACKER I
PORCHES NO BRADFORD I HAVE A.
CORTESE I DALLY NO DODD THEY'RE
AWESOME I EGGMAN FIVE GLAZER NO
GONZALEZ HI GROSS NO HERTZBERG
WESTERN HI HER TADO NO JONES NO
CAN LONGER LAYERED I LLEVA FIVE
THE MON I REQUIRE I MELINDA'S
NO MAN I NEWMAN NIELSEN NO A
TRIO OF BOTH NO PAN FIVE
FOURTEEN TINA I. ROSS FIVE
RUBIO SKINNER I STERN I AMBERG
WHITE HOUSE E. WINNER I WILL NO
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ALAN I AT KINS CONFIRA DODD
HERTZBERG CAN LONGER I NEWMAN
RUBIO I AMBERG HI I Y. CASKEY.
FIVE TWENTY THREE KNOWS THE
LEVIN MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHTY
EIGHT SENATOR BECKER. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL TEN TWENTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MULLEN AN ACT
RELATING TO HOUSING AND
DECLARING THE URGENCY THERE
OBJECT MEDIALLY SENATOR BECKER
THE FLOOR IS YOURS THE
PRESIDENT MEMBERS WE ARE AWARE
OF THE MASSIVE SHORTAGE OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THE STATE
AND AS TIME PASSES MANY FOR
BUILDING CONFIDENCE REACHED OUR
TIME LIMITS AND EXPIRE. EXPIRE
THE UNIT THAT CAN BE LEASED AT
MARKET RATE EACH UNIT RESETS TO
MARKET RATE THERE IS ONE LESS A
PORTABLE UNIT THAT IS AVAILABLE
TO LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLD THIS
BILL AT THE CALIFORNIA
PERMANENT HOUSING AND COMMUTED
ALL MEANT TO ADD PRESERVATION
OF AFFORDABLE UNITS TO THE LIST
OF PRIORITIES FOR ALLOCATION OF
STATE FUNDING. IT'S MUCH EASIER
TO SAVE A UNIT FROM CONVERTED
TO MARKET RATE THE BILL TO
BRAND NEW UNIT EXPECT LAST YEAR
I VOTE IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SINGMAN
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ALAN ARCHULETA I. ATKINS.
EIGHT. BACKER HI FORTUS. NO
BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM HI
COURTESY I DALLY. NO DODD ALSO
BY ADMIN. FIVE GLAZER FIVE
DOLLARS I GROSS NO HERTZBERG
WHY SO ALL RIGHT HER TADO HI
JONES NO CAN LONGER I LAYERED I
LLEVA FIVE THE MON I REQUIRE I
MELINDA'S NO MEN I NEWMAN
NIELSEN NO A SHOW OF BOTH NO
PAN FIVE FOURTEEN TINA I
BROUGHT HI RUBIO. HI SKINNER I
STERN I AM BERG I LIKE HOW SKI
WINNER I WILL KNOW PLEASE CALL
THE UP TO MEMBERS ALAN I ATKINS
BASED NO DOT HERTZBERG NEWMAN
WHITE HOUSE SKI. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. AT KINS WE
DON'T HAVE GOD HERTZBERG NEWMAN
WHITE HOUSE SKI.
THE CALL
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBER EIGHTY NINE.
SENATOR JONES IS PREPARED MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL TEN THIRTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER VIA PADILLA AN
ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT SENATOR JOSEPH
FLOOR'S YOURS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT RISES A PRODUCT CO
AUTHORED TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL TEN THIRTY ONE TODAY. THIS
BILL REQUIRES STATE AGENCIES TO
GIVE ADDITIONAL PREFERENCE TO
SURVIVORS OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING
WHEN HIRING FOR INTERNSHIPS AND
STUDENT ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS.
ACCORDING TO THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE HUMAN
TRAFFICKING IS AMONG THE
WORLD'S FASTEST GROWING
CRIMINAL ENTERPRISES ESTIMATED
TO BE A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
BILLION DOLLAR A YEAR GLOBAL
INDUSTRY. WITH MANY INDIVIDUALS
BEING FORCED INTO INTO- INTO
THIS INDUSTRY DO TO PROP
POVERTY OR LACK OF EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES MAYBE TEN THIRTY
ONE WILL HELP SURVIVORS OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING ATTAIN
ECONOMIC EMPOWERMENT. THUS
HELPING PREVENT THEM FROM BEING
RE VICTIMIZED MEMBERS I
SINCERELY ASPIRIN I VOTE ON A.
B. TEN THIRTY ONE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MEMBERS IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE ADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALAN
ARCHULETA HI AT KINS BATES I
BACKER I PORCHES HI BRADFORD I
COME BY ADAM HI CORTEZ C. I.
DALLY I DON THERE ARE SO HI
EGGMAN I ALWAYS- HI
CONSOLIDATES FIVE GROWTH BY
HERTZ BERG WEST SO HI HER TADO
HI JONES I CAN LONGER. I
LAYERED I LLEVA FIVE THE MON HI
MCGUIRE HI MELINDA'S FIVE MEN I
NEWMAN NIELSEN HI I- TELEVOTE I
CAN HI FORTUNE TINO I. ROSS HI
RUBIO HI SKINNER I STERN HI
AMBERG HI WHITE HOUSE SKI
WINNER FIVE WELL I PLEASE CALL
THE OB TO MEMBER ALAN I ATKINS
DODD HERTZBERG NEWMAN WHITE
HOUSE GATE FIVE THIRTY FIVE NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES NUMBERS
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER NINETY
SENATOR PAT IS PREPARED MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL ELEVEN NINETY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY AN ACT
RELATED TRANSPORTATION CENTER
DOWN THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT SENATORS I
RISE TODAY TO PRESENT AT ELEVEN
NINETY SIX A. DISTRICT BILL-
FROM SOME MEMBER COOLLY
RELATING TO THE SACRAMENTO
REGIONAL TRANSIT BOARD OF
DIRECTORS VOTING STRUCTURE. IN
TWO THOUSAND SIX THANK R. T.
CHANGES VOTING STRUCTURE TO
WEIGHTED VOTING STRUCTURE-
BASED ON THE EACH VOTING
ENTITIES FINANCIAL CONTRIBUTION
HOWEVER ON APRIL TWENTY TWENTY
ONE A FINAL PARTICIPATING
ENTITY THE CITY VELCRO. HAS A
NEXT INSTRUMENT TRANSIT
SERVICES IN THE SACK R. T. SO
THEREFORE THE VOTE WEIGHTED
VOTING STRUCTURES NO LONGER
NECESSARY SO AT ELEVEN NINETY
SIX WERE REVISED SADC RT'S BODY
STRUCTURE- ACCORDINGLY AND- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I VOTED
HAS FOUR BY SECULAR T. AND THAT
PERHAPS MAYBE. IN HOPE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. THANK YOU
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE THIS ITEM ANY
DISCUSSION- BASING NONE THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
SEEING NINE FIVE THIRTY FIVE NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WILL MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER NINETY THREE SENATOR
MCGUIRE HE IS READY MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL FOURTEEN OH TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVIN AN ACT
RELATING TO TAXATION A GUARD
THE FLOOR'S YOURS SENATE
PRESIDENT GOOD MORNING AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH IN THE
MORNING MEMBERS AT FOURTEEN OH
TWO IS A GOOD BILL BY SOMEONE
OVER THE VAN IT STANDARDIZES
THE COLLECTION OF AN APARTMENT
ON IMPACT FEES AND CERTAIN
RETAIL PRODUCTS SOLD BY MARKET
PLACE TO SOLICITORS ONLINE
WEBSITES- IN CALIFORNIA
INCREASE HE COMPLAINED TO
MAXIMIZE REVENUE. DEFINED
CRUCIAL ENVIRONMENTAL
MITIGATION PROGRAMS THAT IS A
MEMBER'S AND WORKING HARD WITH
OPPOSITION- AND AT LEAST NINE
STATES CURRENTLY REQUIRE
MARKETPLACES STILL TEARS A
COLLECTOR IN IT FEES OR TAXES
IN ADDITION TO SALES AND USE
TAX. IN. WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AND I HAVE A IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALAN
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS BATES HI
BECKER. FIVE PORGES FIVE
BRADFORD I KERR BY OTHER I
COURTESY I DALLY GOD THEY'RE
ALSO HI ADNAN I BELIEVE HER
FIVE DOLLARS I GROSS ARE YOU
HURTS BERG WESTERN HI HER TADO
FIVE JONES CAN LONGER. WHERE DO
I LIVE UN I LIVE ALONE I
REQUIRE I MELINDA'S NO MAN HI
NEWMAN NIELSEN NO HOTEL OR BOTH
HI PAM HI FOURTEEN TINA HI
RALPH HI RUBIO I SKINNER I
STERN I AM BERG I LIKE ASKING
WINNER I WILL NO. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ALAN I AT
KINS DALLY NO DODD HERTZBERG
JONES NO. CAN LONGER I NEWMAN
CASCADE. FIVE THIRTY EIGHT
KNOWS FIVE THE MEASURE PASSES
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER NINETY EIGHT SENATOR HER
TIED UP IS PREPARED PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN EIGHTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAY AN
ACT RELATING TO OCCUPATIONAL
SAFETY SENATOR HER TADO THE
FLOOR'S YOURS THANK YOU MAN
PRESENT. EIGHTY SEVEN EIGHTY
THREE IS A SIMPLE MEASURE TO
IMPROVE WORKPLACE SAFETY AT
SURFACE MINING OPERATIONS THE
BILL REQUIRES THAT STATE
INSPECTORS REPORT HOUSES WITHIN
SEVENTY TWO HOURS SO THEY CAN
BE ADDRESSED AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE. CURRENTLY HAZARDS MAY
NOT BE REPORTED FOR WEEKS OR
MONTHS AFTER INSPECTION BY
CONTRAST BETTER INSPECTORS.
ISSUE REPORTS AT THE CONCLUSION
OF THE INSPECTION OR WITHIN
TWENTY FOUR HOURS A. B. SEVENTY
THREE WILL INSURE STATE
INSPECTORS ARE HIGHLY WORKPLACE
HAZARDS IN A TIMELY FASHION.
THERE IS NO OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL THIS BILL HAS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN A RESPECTFUL ASPIRIN
ABOUT FOR ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE ITEM ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SINGMAN
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I
ARCHULETA I AT KINS BASE HI
BECKER. FIVE FOR JUST FIVE
BRADFORD I HAVE A I DON'T I
COURTESY I DALLY. SALLY DOT
TORONTO I HAD GIVEN I GLAZER HI
CONSOLIDATES FIVE GROVE FIVE
THIRDS BERG WHY SO HI HER TADO
FIVE JONES. FIVE CAN LONGER I
LAYERED HI LLEVA I THE MON I AM
A WIRE. MCGUIRE HI MELINDA'S
FIVE MEN HI NEWMAN NIELSEN I-
TELEVOTE HI TAM FIVE PERSONS
YOU KNOW HI ROTH I REVIEW I
SKINNER I STERN I AM BERG I
LIKE HOW SKI WINNER I WILL HI
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ATKINS DALLY I DODD ERTZ BERG
NEWMAN WHITE HOUSE SKI. FIVE
THIRTY FIVE NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER
NINETY NINE SENATOR BRADFORD IS
READY. PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHT NINETY BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SERVE ON TENNIS AN ACT
RELATING TO PUBLIC RETIREMENT
SYSTEMS CENTER BRADFORD THE
FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. AV EIGHT NINE IS A
COMMON SENSE MEASURE TO SIMPLY
REQUIRES CALPERS AND CAL STIRS
REPORT TO USE OF EMERGING AND
DIVERSE MONEY MANAGERS CALPERS
AND CAL STIRS HAVE COMBINED
ASSETS OF OVER SEVEN HUNDRED
BILLION DOLLARS BUT A LOW RATE
OF PARTICIPATION IN EMERGING
AND DIVERSE MANAGERS WHEN
COMPARED TO OTHER. PENSION
SYSTEMS TODAY ONLY 1% OF
VENTURE CAPITAL BACKED
FOUNDERS. ARE BLACK ELECTION
TWO PERCENT- LET MAX SIMILARLY
WOMEN RECEIVE A DOZEN ALL TWO
POINT 7% OF VENTURE CAPITAL
FUNDING FOR WOMEN OF COLOR IT'S
LESS THAN 1% OF THE VENTURE
CAPITAL FUNDING IT IS CLEAR
THAT THERE IS INEQUITIES AND
BIASES AND RACISM THAT EXIST IN
THE SYSTEMS. OF SELECT MANAGERS
TO INVEST ALL HOW THEY SHOULD
SAY THEY SELECT MANAGERS TO
INVEST THEIR CAPITAL THAT THEY
OVERSEE CALIFORNIA CANNOT SHEER
SUCCESS WITHOUT SHARED
OPPORTUNITY THIS BILL WILL HELP
TO ENSURE THAT WOMEN AND PEOPLE
OF COLOR HAVE MORE ACCESS-
EQUAL ACCESS TO CAPITAL AND
MAKING IT CLEAR THAT THE
CALPERS AND CAL STIRS- CHOOSES
TO INVEST I SIMPLY ASK FOR
YOUR- VOTE. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALAN I
ARCHULETA HI AT KINS BAIT NO
BACKER I FOR JUST BRADFORD I
COME BY ADAM HI CHRIS HAS HE
FIVE DALLY NO DODD THERE ALSO
HI ADNAN I BELIEVE HER HI
CONSOLIDATES FIVE GROWTH NO
HERTZBERG WAY SO HI HER TADO HI
JONES NO CAMCORDER I LAYERED I
LABOR I THE MOON I REQUIRE I
MELINDA'S NO MEN FIVE NEWMAN
NIELSEN NO A TELEPHONE NO PAM I
PERSON TINA I. ROSS I RUBIO I
SKINNER I STERN I AM BERG I
LIKE HOW SKI WINNER I WILL YEAH
NOW. PLEASE CALL THE OB TO
MEMBERS ATKINS GORGEOUS DODD
HERTZBERG NEWMAN WHITE HOUSE K.
FIVE TWENTY SIX KNOWS EIGHT THE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WERE
GOING TO GO BACK. TWO
UNFINISHED BUSINESS SENATOR
LEYVA TAKING UP FILE ITEM
NUMBER EIGHTEEN MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL TWO
NINETY FOUR BY SENATOR LEYVA AN
ACT RELATINGTO PUBLIC
RETIREMENT AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE CENTER
LABEL THE FORGERS THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS EIGHTY TWO NINETY FOUR
IS BACK FROM CONCURRENCE
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IT IS SOME OF
THE FAMILY WERE CLARIFYING AND
DID NOT SUBSTANTIALLY CHANGE
THE BILL. SB TWO NINETY FOUR
SIMPLY REMOVES A TWELVE YEAR
MAXIMUM SERVICE CREDIT CAP THAT
CAN BE EARNED BY AN EDUCATOR TO
ENSURE PARITY WITH OTHER EVERY
OTHER PUBLIC PUBLIC EMPLOYEE
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
IPHONE. OR ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SAYING NO.
SEE NO FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I
ARCHULETA. I AT KINS. EIGHT NO
BACKER I PORCHES NO BRADFORD
I'VE COME BY ADAM HI COURTESY I
DALLY NO DODD THEY'RE ALSO BY
ADMIN GLAZER FIVE DOLLARS HI
GROVE NO HERTZBERG WEST SO HER
TADO HI JONES NO CAN LONGER I
LAYERED I LLEVA I THE MON I
WIRE HI MELINDA'S NO MEN FIVE
NEWMAN NIELSEN NO TELEVOTE NO
PAM HI FORTUNE TINO I. ROSS HI
RUBIO FIVE SKINNER HI STERN I
AM BERG I LIKE HOW SKI WINNER I
WILL NOW PLEASE CALL THE OB TO
MEMBERS ATKINS I DODD EGGMAN I
HERTZBERG WEST SO I NEWMAN
WHITE HOUSE SKI. HIGHS TWENTY
SEVEN KNOWS NINE B. ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS ARE GONNA LET THE CALL
AN ITEM NUMBER EIGHTY EIGHT.
MADAM SECRETARY. ATKINS I DIED
HERTZBERG NEWMAN WHITE HOUSE
GATE. FIVE TWENTY SEVEN KNOWS
NINE ON THE URGENCY EYES TWENTY
SEVEN KNOWS NINE ON THE MEASURE
MEASURE PASSES. BACK TO MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS MEMBERS SENATOR
ALAN. YOU ASKED THAT WE REMOVED
AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY FROM THE
CONSENT FILE FOR PURPOSES OF A
NEMESIS IS A COMMITTEE BILL
AROUND THE SAME EXACT FIFTEEN
SEVENTY. IF SO ORDERED. MEMBERS
ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO. ARE
THERE ANY OTHER MOTIONS OR
RESOLUTIONS. SEEING THEN WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE UP THE ADJOURNING
MEMORIES COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS MY APOLOGIES
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS SENATOR
PORTEND TINO. THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
WILL CONVENE- AT THE SAME TIME
THAT THE SENATE NEXT MOVIE TO
ME THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS WILL CONVENE THE
SAME TIME THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CONVENES SOME WILL BE
MONITORING THAT SOME MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE KEEP TABS ON THAT
WILL BE CONTACTING YOUR OFFICES
I WOULD ANTICIPATE SOMETIME
BETWEEN ELEVEN- THIRTY AND
TWELVE O'CLOCK VERY GOOD SEVEN
NOTED THE IS THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE WILL BE INFORMED OF
EXACTLY WHEN THE COMMITTEE WILL
START. OKAY MEMBERS ARE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORIES WE'LL START WITH
SENATOR PENN. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT- CENTERS IT WAS A
HEAVY HEAVY HEART THAT ARISE TO
GERMAN REFRAIN TO KERIKERI
SACRAMENTO RESTAURATEUR IN
BUSINESS ICON WHEN HE WAS
SEVENTY FOUR YEARS OLD AND HE
GAVE A LIVE THE LIFE OF SERVICE
AND PASSION FOR CREATING SPACES
FOR PEOPLE TO COME TOGETHER AND
ENJOY THEMSELVES READY WHAT'S
ONE OF THE MOST PROLIFIC
BUSINESS OWNERS IN SACRAMENTO
CREATING CONCEPTS THAT BROUGHT
LIFE INTO THE CITY INJURED.
INTRODUCED US TO MANY CULINARY
DELIGHTS HE OPENED HIS FIRST
RESTAURANT IN NINETEEN SIXTY
NINE WE JUST TWENTY THREE YEARS
OLD. THIS FIRST BAR AND
RESTAURANT IS MOTIVATED IN PART
BY HIS DESIRE TO FIGHT FOR EACH
SERVICE AND FOOD TO PATRONS OF
ALL BACKGROUNDS. IN ADDITION TO
ITS HOSPITALITY RANDY IS MOST
KNOWN FOR ALWAYS STAYING AHEAD
OF THE CHANGING HOSPITALITY
NIGHTLIFE INDUSTRY ESTABLISHING
HIMSELF AS THE OFFICIAL HOST OF
SACRAMENTO PACMAN SOME OF
RANDY'S ESTABLISHMENTS HAVE
BEEN HOST TO MANY LEGISLATIVE
EVENTS RECEPTION I'M SURE THAT
MANY OF YOU HAVE RECORDED HIS
ESTABLISHMENT. I SHOULD MAKE
NOTE THAT ACTION MY FIRST DATE
WITH MY WIFE WAS AT ONE OF HIS
RESTAURANTS RANDY HAD A LOT OF
FUN DOING WHAT HE LOVED TO DO.
PEOPLE DESCRIBE RANDY IS
SOMEONE WHO IS IN THE MIX AND
THE MOMENT LIKE YOU THROWING A
PARTY THREE HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE
DAYS A YEAR EQUALLY AS FUN
RANDY IS KNOWN FOR MENTORING
AND INSPIRING DOZENS OF
RESTAURATEURS IN CALLING
PROFESSIONALS HAVE GONE ON TO
EXPERIENCE SUCCESS ON THEIR OWN
VENTURES AND- EAT SO MANY OF
THEM- YOU PROBABLY ALSO ENJOYED
THOSE RESTAURANTS AS WELL RANDY
PERRY GERRY'S IMPACT ON THE
LIVES OF OTHERS IN THE REGION
SACRAMENTO BE MISSED BUT NEVER
FORGOTTEN. I ASKED AT THE
SENATE ADJOURNED IN MEMORY OF
OUR FRIENDS THE HOST OF
SACRAMENTO RANDY PLEASE EXTEND
THE SENATE CONDOLENCES TO THE
FAMILY AND BRING THE NAME
FORWARD TO THE DESK SO HE CAN
BE APPROPRIATELY MEMORIALIZED
SENATOR LEYVA THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS IT WAS WITH
GREAT SADNESS THAT I ASKED THAT
WE ADJOURNED TODAY IN THE
MEMORY OF LOIS CARSON OF
SAMPOERNA DINO IT WAS CARSON
WAS BORN TO WILLIAM AND FERNET
IN MONTGOMERY ON JULY THIRD
NINETEEN THIRTY ONE IN MEMPHIS
TENNESSEE WHERE SHE ATTENDED ST
AUGUSTINE CATHOLIC HIGH SCHOOL.
AS VALEDICTORIAN OF HER HIGH
SCHOOL SHE WON A SCHOLARSHIP
FROM THE UNITED NEGRO COLLEGE
FUND TO ATTEND WILBERFORCE
UNIVERSITY. THE OLDEST
HISTORICALLY BAD BLACK
UNIVERSITY IN AMERICA SHE
EARNED HER BACHELOR'S DEGREE
FROM CSU SAMBAR TO DINO THE
CAMPUSES FIRST GRADUATING CLASS
AND TWO MASTERS DEGREE DEGREES
FROM UC RIVERSIDE MRS CARSON
SERVED TWENTY FOUR YEARS AS A
SAMBAR DINO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT TRUSTEE SHE TAUGHT THE
U. C. R. UPWARD BOUND PROGRAM
IN VENUES AS FAR AWAY AS
AFRICA. AND ALSO SERVED THIRTY
YEARS AS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE COMMUNITY ACTION
PARTNERSHIP IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY. AS A COMMUNITY ACTIVIST
CARSON WAS A FOUNDER OF
NUMEROUS LOCAL ORGANIZATIONS IN
THE INLAND EMPIRE GARNERING
COUNTLESS PRESTIGIOUS AWARDS
FOR HER COMMITMENT TO
CONTINUING EDUCATION AND HER
COMMUNITY HER MANTRA WAS
EDUCATION IS THE SUREST PATHWAY
OUT OF POVERTY. SOME OF HER
OWNERS INCLUDED THE PAPAL MEDAL
FROM POPE JOHN PAUL THE SECOND
HUMANITARIAN AWARDS AND
COUNTLESS OTHER DISTINGUISHED
HONORS. SHE'S EVEN RECOGNIZED
IN THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
COLLEGE ALUMNI HALL OF FAME.
WITH HER TIRELESS EFFORTS TO
BETTER HER COMMUNITY SHE HELPED
TENS OF THOUSANDS WITH ENERGY
ASSISTANCE FOOD IN RENTAL
ASSISTANCE JOBS AND SKILLS
TRAINING AND ADVOCACY FOR THE
HOMELESS. LOWS CHERSON HAD FIVE
CHILDREN SIX GRANDCHILDREN AND
FIVE GREAT GRANDCHILDREN AND
WILL BE GREATLY MISSED BY ALL
OF HER FAMILY AND FRIENDS BUT
THE LEGACY SHE LEFT BEHIND WILL
SURELY NOT BE FORGOTTEN MEMBERS
I WANT TO END WITH ONE OF MISS
CARSON'S FAVORITE QUOTES I
SHALL PASS THIS WAY BUT ONCE.
IF THERE BE SOMETHING I CAN DO
LET ME DO IT NOW FOR I SHALL
PASS THIS WAY BUT ONCE MEMBERS
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A JOURNEY IN
MEMORY. OF LOIS CARSON PLEASE
BRING THE NAME FORWARD TO THE
DEATHS OF YET SHE MAY BE
APPROPRIATELY MEMORIALIZED BY
THE SENATE SENATOR DOLLY. THANK
YOU THANK YOU MADAM THANK YOU
MADAM THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
I RISE TODAY TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF KIM TOLD US HE WAS
RAISED IN AUBURN CALIFORNIA AT
A. O. HEIGHTS WITH HIS MOTHER
BLAIR AND FATHER DORMANT BIG
JIM DAVIS DORMAN WOULD INSTILL
THE LOVE OF RUNNING CATTLE AND
DRIVING TRUCKS FROM RANCH TO
RANCH AND HIS SON JIMMY BEYOND
LIFE ON THE RANCH SOME OF GEMS
FOUNDERS CHILDHOOD MEMORIES
WERE THE SUMMER SPENT IN MEEKS
BAY LAKE TAHOE AT THE FAMILY
CABIN A PLUS OR HIGH SCHOOL HE
MET BARBARA MCKENZIE. AND A
HIGH SCHOOL SWEET HEARTS WOULD
BE WOULD BE MARRIED IN NINETEEN
FIFTY TWO. IN TIME THEY WOULD
WELCOME THEIR TWO CHILDREN
DANNY AND DONNIE HIS EXPERIENCE
WITH TRUCKS WOULD LAND HIM A
JOB. WITH CAROLINA HAULING LOGS
IN NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT. HE
WOULD TAKE HIS PETERBILT TRUCK
AND LAUNCH HIS OWN BUSINESS IN
THE TRUCKING TRANSPORTATION.
UNDER HIS NAMESAKE JAMMED OVER
SINK ON THE MORNING OF APRIL
TWENTY EIGHT NINETEEN SEVENTY
THREE JIM'S TRUCKING CAREER
WOULD CHANGE FOREVER. HE WAS
STARTLED. BY THE SOUND OF BOMBS
GOING OFF AT THE SOUTHERN
PACIFIC. RAILYARD IN ROSEVILLE
CALIFORNIA JIM JUMPED IN HIS
TRUCK AND HUSTLE TO FIND OUT-
FIND UTTER CHAOS. IT WAS THERE
THAT HIS CLEAN UP WORK LAUNCHED
FOR THE SOUTHERN PACIFIC
RAILROAD. THAT WOULD DEVELOP
INTO A RAILROAD DERAILMENTS
SERVICE THROUGHOUT NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA NEVADA UTAH AND
SOUTHERN OREGON. JIM IT'S BEEN
NEARLY THE NEXT THIRTY YEARS ON
CALL TWENTY FOUR HOURS A DAY.
RE RAILING TRAINS FOR MULTIPLE
ROADWAYS IN THE WESTERN REGION
OF THE UNITED STATES JIM WAS A
LONG TIME MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA CATTLEMEN'S
ASSOCIATION. HE WAS THOROUGHLY
COMMITTED TO SUPPORTING LOCAL
FOUR H. AND FFA AND JUNIOR
LIVESTOCK AUCTION PROGRAMS ALL
THE PASSIONS THAT JIM HAD
THROUGHOUT HIS LIFE. ONE PART
ON THE CAPTIVE HIS WHOLE BEING
THE LOVE FOR ANTIQUE TRUCKSTRUCKS FROM MILES AWAY WAS
EXTRAORDINARY. ANYTHING FROM A
LOGGING TRUCK FIRE TRUCK TO AN
ARMY TRUCK HE SAW A PIECE OF
GOLD IN EVERYONE OF THESE
ANTIQUES REMEMBER A MAN WHO
LIVED EVERY SINGLE DAY WITH THE
PURPOSE AND PASSION. AND WHO IT
HAD GREAT LOVE FOR HIS AUBURN
AND SIERRA BILL COMMUNITIES JIM
IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE CAROL.
BELOVED DOG GEORGE. STEP FAMILY
DAUGHTER CASEY HER HUSBAND
CHASE GRANDSON LAYTON NIECE
AMY. HIS CHILDREN DANNY AND
DAWN WIFE LINDA AND
GRANDCHILDREN HEATHER HANNAH
AND FAIR. HUSBAND MARK DILLON
AND A WHITE MADISON A GRAND AND
GREAT GRANDCHILDREN COLMAN
ALLEY DANE AND GRANT TODAY I
ASKED YOU ADJOURNED IN HIS
MEMORY AS WELL I'D LIKE TO NOTE
THAT ERA HIS- GRANDDAUGHTER WAS
ALSO- WORK FOR THE ASSEMBLY.
REPUBLICAN CAUCUS AS WELL SO IN
HIS MEMORY I WOULD LIKE TO JOIN
THANK YOU SENATOR PLEASE BRING
HIS NAME FOR TODAY SO THAT HE
MAY BE APPROPRIATELY
MEMORIALIZED SENATOR ALAN
THERE'S IT'S WITH WITH GREAT
SADNESSWROTE WAS A CARING AND GENEROUS
COMPASSIONATE MAN. ALL WHO KNEW
HIM KNEW THAT HIS CHARACTER-
AND INDEED IN LIFE EXCEEDED
GRATITUDE AND RESPECT FOR
OTHERS. HE WAS BORN IN NINETEEN
THIRTY FIVE IN BROOKLYN NEW
YORK AND FLATBUSH NEIGHBORHOOD.
I HAD A KIND OF A HARD
SCRABBLE- BEGINNING. HE
ATTENDED A RASMUS HIGH SCHOOL
IN LONG ISLAND UNIVERSITY IN
BROOKLYN BEFORE MOVING TO LA TO
START A CAREER IN THE SAMATA
BUSINESS GOVERNMENT CAREER IT'S
IN THE MID SEVENTIES ALONG WITH
HIS WIFE ALICE HE CO FOUNDED
CITY TRIANGLES IN APPAREL AND
FASHION COMPANY THAT BECAME A
VENUE FOR HIS PERSONAL
PROFESSIONAL LIFE. FOR DECADES
THE VERY SUCCESSFUL CAREER. IN
FASHION TEXTILES AND CLOTHING
HE'LL BE REMEMBERED FOR HIS
STRENGTH HIS PATIENCE IS LOVE
SPORTS HIS SENSE OF HUMOR AND
INDOMITABLE SPIRIT THAT. THE NO
BOUNDS HE WAS VERY GENEROUS.
THE FREQUENT DONOR TO THE
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL LOS ANGELES
CEDARS SINAI MEDICAL CNTER
PROVIDENCE ST JOHN'S HEALTH
CENTER THE CITY OF HOPE HIS
COMPANY- CITY TRIANGLES HAD A
SPECIAL PARTNERSHIP DONATING
PROM DRESSES TO THE CINDERELLA
PROJECT. OF LOS ANGELES IT IS
BASICALLY PROVIDED
UNDERPRIVILEGED GIRLS WITH FREE
DRESSES ACCESSORIES AND SHOES
FOR THEIR PROMS OR GRADUATION
NIGHTS AND REALLY. MADE PROM
NIGHT A MAGICAL NIGHT FOR IT
FOR SO MANY YOUNG WOMEN AROUND.
THE LA AREA JUST TO GIVE YOU A
SENSE IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
ALONE OVER FIVE HUNDRED TEENS
FROM FIFTY TWO HIGH SCHOOLS
BENEFITED FROM THIS WONDERFUL
PROGRAM WHERE THEY WERE GIVEN.
FREE CLOTHING TO MAKE IT A
SPECIAL NIGHT I LOVE PLAYING
BASKETBALL CYCLING IF I WOULD
USE A SHORT GUY BUT HE WAS
INDOMITABLE ON THE COURT. GOT A
CHANCE TO PLAY WITH THEM ONCE
OR TWICE USE A CYCLIST SKIER
RUNNER HORSEBACK RIDERS A ROAD
IS HARDLY TRAVEL ENTERTAINMENT
HOSTED PARTIES AND- WAS A
COURSE IN LA. LAKERS SEASON
TICKET HOLDER FOR A WHILE HE
JUST STARTED GOLFING IN HIS
RETIREMENT. HE SUCCEEDED BY HIS
WIFE ALICE IN TWENTY FIVE YEARS
FIVE CHILDREN ROBERT DAVID
ANITA ALLISON AND CHRISTOPHER.
AND THEIR SPOUSES HIS ELEVEN
GRANDCHILDREN IS ONE AND IS ONE
GREAT GRANDCHILD- I GREW UP
WITH HIS DAUGHTER IN NEED AND
WE WENT TO MIDDLE SCHOOL
TOGETHER IN HIGH SCHOOL AND
BECAME VERY CLOSE FRIENDS WITH
THEIR NEED TO. HAVE A CHANCE TO
GO OVER TO THEIR HOUSE MANY
TIMES WENT TO PARTIES THERE.
AND I WILL ALWAYS I ALWAYS HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO TALK TO IRAN
EVEN AS A KID HE ALWAYS TOOK AN
INTEREST IN ME WE HAD WONDERFUL
CONVERSATIONS. AND AS I GREW IN
AND AS MY CAREER BEGAN TO
PROGRESS HE ALWAYS. WAS PUSHING
ME TO. ADD TO IT TO KEEP
PUSHING MYSELF. AND ALWAYS
ENCOURAGING ME ALWAYS
SUPPORTING ME AND I WILL ALWAYS
APPRECIATE THE INTEREST THAT HE
TOOK AND THE GENEROSITY YOU
SHOWED IN THE SUPPORT HE SHOWED
FOR ME I DID SHE JUST GOT A
CHANCE THIS THIS LAST WEEKEND
TO GO DOWN TO LOS ANGELES. WE
HAD AN OUTDOOR CELEBRATION OF
HIS LIFE IN BRENTWOOD AND- THEY
WERE JUST WONDERFUL STORIES
PEOPLE GOT UP AND TALKED ABOUT
HIS GENEROSITY HIS CHARACTER
AND HOW MUCH WE MISS HIM AND
HOW MUCH HE LEFT US FAR TOO
SOON AND SO I HI. I'M GONNA
MISS HIM MYSELF HE'S A GOOD
GOOD MAN AND I JUST LIKE TO ASK
COLLEAGUES THAT WE ALL. THE
JOURNEY IN HIS MEMORY THANK YOU
THANK YOU SENATOR ALAN PLEASE
BE BRING HIS NAME FORWARD SO HE
MAY BE PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED AT
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE SENATOR
CALERO. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. I RISE TODAY WITH
GREAT SORROW DEVASTATED BY THE
SUDDEN SUDDEN TRAGIC PASSING OF
MY DEAR FRIEND AND COLLEAGUE
OFFERED THE S. AND FUN DAY
POVERTY ISN'T FOUND THERE WAS A
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF CHEESE BUT
WHICH MEANS SPARK MONTEREY
COUNTY'S LARGEST NONPROFIT
HOUSING ORGANIZATION WHICH IS
PROVIDED HOMEOWNERSHIP AND
RENTAL OPPORTUNITIES TO
THOUSANDS OF LOW INCOME
FAMILIES MOSTLY FARMERS.
OFFERED DSM FUNDRAISING KIT
COMMITMENT TO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WAS ROUTED IN ITS OWN
STORY AS A SON OF IMMIGRANT
FARMWORKERS AND WHOSE PARENTS
RAISED A FAMILY AND BUILT A
HOME. AND A FAMILY IN THE CITY
OF SALINAS THIS EXPERIENCE
CHANGED THE ENTIRE FAMILY HIS
PARENTS BECAME MORE ENGAGED IN
THEIR CHILDREN'S EDUCATION. AND
COMMUNITY ONCE THEY WERE
ESTABLISHED AND HAD A HOME OF
THEIR OWN IT ALSO CHANGED
ALFRED HE UNDERSTOOD THE
CORRELATION BETWEEN HAVING A
HOME AND HAVING A PLACE IN THE
COMMUNITY BEING A PART OF THE
COMMUNITY AND FEELING WELCOME.
MR DS IN FRONT THERE REMAIN
COMMITTED TO THE MISSION OF
CHEESE BUT FOR OVER TWO DECADES
WHERE YOU EXCELLED PUTTING
TOGETHER MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
COMPLEX FINANCIAL PRO FORMAS.
TO BUILD AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR
FAMILIES I OWE MUCH OF WHAT I
KNOW ABOUT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
TO ALFRED. TOGETHER AS A CITY
COUNCILMEMBER AND MAYOR I VOTED
TO ALLOCATE PRECIOUS CITY
RESOURCES TO HELP CHILDREN
SHE'S BACK BUILD AFFORDABLE
HOMES IN THE CITY OF SALINAS.
OUR HOME I SAW FAMILIES BUILD
THEIR OWN HOMES IN CHEESE BY
SELF HELP OWNERSHIP PROJECTS I
WITNESSED THIS IS STATIC
CHILDREN CLEAN THEIR OWN ROOMS
AS THEY MOVED IN AND ABLE TO BE
BELIEVE THAT THEY FINALLY HAD A
HOME AND A ROOM OF THEIR OWN.
THIS EXPERIENCE CHANGED ME AS
WELL TO THIS DAY IT DRIVES ME
TO ADVOCATE FOR OUTSIDE THE BOX
POLICIES TO MAKE IT EASIER TO
BUILD HOUSING. IN MY WORK AS A
PLANNING COMMISSIONER MAYOR
ASSEMBLYWOMAN AND NOW IT'S A
STATE SENATOR I CAN ALWAYS RELY
ON OFFER DECENT FUNDED TO
PROVIDE INSIGHT ASSISTANCE AND
CONSTRUCTIVE FEEDBACK ON
HOUSING POLICY ISSUES TO HELP
BUILD. MORE HOUSING OFFERED THE
S. AND FUN TO ALWAYS LOOK FOR
OPPORTUNITIES TO SERVE OTHERS
AND HIS COMMITMENT TO LOW
INCOME FAMILIES LED HIM TO
SERVE ON NUMEROUS BOARDS
INCLUDING THE COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION FOR MONTEREY COUNTY
THE SALINAS. VALLEY MEMORIAL
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM MONTEREY BAY
ECHO ECONOMIC PARTNERSHIP THE
BIG SUR LAND TRUST AND THE
HARTNELL COLLEGE FOUNDATION HE
WAS ALSO DEDICATED TO PUBLIC
SERVICE. IN TWO THOUSAND THREE
HE RECEIVED A FELLOW AWARD FOR
COMMUNITY AND PUBLIC SERVICE.
IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN HE WAS
NAMED THE SALINAS VALLEY
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE COMMERCE
CITIZEN OF THE YEAR AND WAS
RECOGNIZED WITH THE OUTSTANDING
LEADERSHIP AWARD FROM THE
HARTNELL. COLLEGE FOUNDATION.
IT IS WITHOUT A DOUBT THE
ALFRED DS INFANTE INVESTED HIS
TIME. TALENT AND MONEY IN MANY
NOTEWORTHY CAUSES THAT MADE A
LASTING IMPACT ON THE LIVES OF
THOSE HE CARED FOR HIS DOUBLES
THE DS IN FRONT THE FAMILY
SCHOLARSHIP FUND. AT OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FOR FARM
WORKERS CHILDREN OF FARMWORKERS
ARE LOW INCOME STUDENTS HIS
ACCOMPLISHMENTS AND ACCOLADES
WERE MANY. AND MONTEREY COUNTY
REGION WILL UNDOUBTEDLY FEEL
HIS LOSS. I WILL MISS HIS
POLICY DISCUSSIONS ON HOUSING
WATER AND OTHER LAND USE ISSUES
BUT MOST OF ALL I WILL MISS HIS
GENTLE SMILE. HIS CALM DEMEANOR
AND HIS WILLINGNESS TO DISCUSS
ISSUES THE TRANSFORM PEOPLE'S
LIFE. LASTLY I WOULD LIKE TO
NOTE THAT ALFRED WORE MANY HATS
AND POSITIVELY IMPACTED OUR
COMMUNITY THERE IS NOTHING MORE
IMPORTANT TO HIM AND HIS
FAMILY. MY HEART GOES OUT TO
HIS WIFE OF THIRTY ONE YEARS L.
VERA HIS CHILDREN CUT ENOUGH.
ALEXIS AND MARCOS AND HIS FOUR
MONTH OLD GRANDSON LEO.
ALFORD'S LEGACY AND COMMITMENT
TO HIS FAMILY. HOUSING
COMMUNITY EQUITY AND JUSTICE
WILL FOREVER BE PART OF THE
SOCIAL FABRIC OF THE SALINAS
VALLEY. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT WE
ADJOURN IN. MEMORY OF ALFRED D.
AS IN FACT THANK YOU SENATOR
COM PLAY BRING HIS NAME FORWARD
SO HE MAY BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. MEMBERS MANY OF YOU
MAY HAVE SEEN THE NEWS PRIOR
TO- PRIOR TO- SENT THE FLOORS
STARTING TODAY. THAT A NUMBER
OF U. S. SERVICE MEMBERS WERE
KILLED IN A COUPLE COUPLE
AIRPORT ATTACK. PENTAGON PRESS
SECRETARY JOHN KIRBY TWEETED
THAT HE CAN CONFIRM THE NUMBER
OF U. S. SERVICE MEMBERS HAVE
BEEN KILLED IN THE AIRPORT
ATTACK THE OFFICIAL ALSO SAID
THAT A NUMBER OF OTHERS ARE
BEING TREATED FOR WOUNDS HE
NOTED THAT THE US IS ALSO AWARE
THAT AFGHANS FELL VICTIM TO
THIS ATTACK. HE DID NOT HOWEVER
PROVIDE EXACT NUMBERS MEMBERS
I'D LIKE ALL OF US TO RISE AND
TAKE A MOMENT OF SILENCE FOR
THESE BRAVE WOMEN AND MEN. WHO
ARE TRYING TO. GET PEOPLE OUT
OF THIS COUNTRY. THANK YOU
MEMBERS. MEMBERS IF THERE IS NO
FURTHER BUSINESS THE SENATOR
BATES THE DESK IS CLEAR THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I NOTICED
THAT THE SENATE WILL BE IN
RECESS UNTIL OUR LEGISLATIVE
BUSINESSES RECEIVED AT THE DESK
AT WHICH TIME THE ADJOURNMENT
MOTION WILL BE PLACED WE WILL
RECONVENE MONDAY AT TWO PM
THANK YOU. THE SENATE WILL BE
IN RECESS UNTIL ALL LEGISLATIVE
BUSINESSES RECEIVED AT THE DESK
AT WHICH TIME THE TOURNAMENT
MOTION WILL BE PLACED WE WILL
RECONVENE MONDAY AT TWO PM
THANK YOU MEMBERS HAVE A GREAT
REST OF THE DAY.